I'm aware to me about this idea now now
starting right now trying to get a real
fast slow down up in our analysis can my
interest about concern at home right now
but I've generally the husband of the
South result I think spending time
debating your state where a level talent
like I've never had that conversation
like it's good to have that belief but
truth is like it's going to manifest one
way or the other
like no a winner ever lost you
understand so like what I would say is
like don't worry about proven s in the
world for T to yourself just give and
then the angle in the action will then
eventually tell the story if you are you
are terrific whether you believe through
available talents you doesn't believe it
it all doesn't matter the end right at
the end it plays out to be the way it is
what's great about did your five in life
is it not like sportswear like other
people control your outset you're in
control
that a lot for me thank you thank you
I wouldn't say more than a [ __ ]
second
everybody's a bigger picture or you'd
like you I mean you're enjoying a right
after my gran like how are you aunt good
are you gonna click [ __ ] yeah different
jacked by the way guys whoa got it thank
you thank you in real crazy real
questions thank you coming out about to
die for real every song thanks for
helping out to see when you win because
so much negativity out there right now
is heartless and it's overcome it you
know not for me but to other people or
I'm going that way yeah so more people
are stopped there to thing probably
around that zero sure look a lot and
I'll get to London beat up just oh I'm
commander coach are Princeton Eddie and
my new best friend
very very cool of it good never just
think it's good for your on yelling yes
I want to think that so much for all
information group everyone genuine to me
get 5 ounces and wanna push it you know
to do do and one more more thanks for
coming appreciate coming your big Iran
how are you nice to meet you I was just
like yeah hugely inspirational I mean a
year ago I'd end up [ __ ] like I watch
your videos all the time now I just
start my first shop investment banking
on Wall Street no I mean just like you
know essentially trying to get in the
entrepreneurial thing just like you know
making mine up before that just saw
something really appreciate every my
pleasure oh thanks for coming like
really cause of death
I appreciate it man thanks for coming
out brother how are you have a t-shirt
yeah she's a real offense pleasure to
finally meet them cornea we all been to
DM we wanted to do a 360 video with you
job charging slicing we have a VR
creative agency production right here in
Union Square love it just want to know
if we could do some work for you some
creative for you cost money we don't
outsource any of that work we do all our
own internal to nuptials so probably not
but if you slide on the for you or lying
I mean daily the best way the best way
for me is even though I talk a lot about
diem yeah I mean yeah diem was tough for
me before I put it out there and now
that I put it out there first of all I
get like I'm doing like 50 check I'm
getting like hit up by every single into
innocence of like Fox you my BM is so
[ __ ] up now I'm getting like 500 GM's
of EXO emails best way to get ahold of
me alright email Vanessa
great awesome is those lesser things
coming
it's coming out two years of stick a
mule
yes and I hit up a couple times sign I'm
like good friends with David at og like
I've been trying to get like three - I
know it's like cuz I I don't think I
will
I've always talked about granary but I'm
a den no boss man yeah he's not a
digital ocean yes like you told me about
you can do how much I love you clearly
yes yeah they should come in I get it
requirement yeah course clear this up
Garin loaf as my nephew Michael couldn't
be here can you just throw a shout out
the microphone the husband that of
course Michael
oh we're filming yeah Michael first of
all let us [ __ ] are you second ball the
only excuse is hustle keep grinding baby
Claire thank you I'm right there oh you
you own really a barbecue laughs really
boring school kind of come here hi
darling question barbershop SW blog I
love a seven I came back here light into
all of those
yes what I like so I got better at it I
came back here and I saw where you want
to go to Nevada senator like I was like
my boys would be like Vince I was like
for my bag immunogenic apocalypse I
still think it's DMing emailing just a
lot of keep asking ask our staff - let
me just say yes somebody's going to
think that your fire made them say yes
and then you do well on your way you go
[Music]
against the market or like do that or
content impatient they'll come to you
you got to put it out there and just
like over time will come to you
obviously hard don't welcome hey good
party game how you doing fella finally
home by waiting your father you're good
at I I knew I was good at early on for
yeah here he come hopeful services uh
I'm good thank you uh I knew what I was
good at early on because I sold [ __ ] and
so I thought it was a Salesman right
like when I was a kid I'm like oh I'm a
Salesman
and I think like I didn't realize thank
you so much I didn't realize I was good
at helping people or bringing value like
I think too many people try to figure
out what the review and instead of
putting [ __ ] bullet and anything we
figure it out at the time everybody
thank you everybody's trying to figure
out [ __ ] beforehand the answer is to
figure [ __ ] out after everybody knows
like when I look around here I see how
young everybody is I'm like [ __ ] man
like everybody if everybody just knew
that they should just work and do [ __ ]
and be [ __ ] and then at 25 and then at
30 and then at 35 and then at 40 assess
assess assess everybody's crippled to
waste time when time is the only thing
they've got like so many people here are
so scarred to do the wrong thing for
three years when they're 20 [ __ ] five
years old and they'll only be told like
everybody's scared of
hard work with no obvious outcome and
that's the only way to get the answer I
never thought about [ __ ] I knew I wanted
to buy the Jets and I was it everything
else I didn't overthink I was like I'm
just going to build this family business
then I'm gonna be this YouTube show then
I'm going to invest in startups I didn't
know what impacting like you know thank
you very much chef down the street ilku
calamari let me I'm do about it than the
into dinner sir thank you all for us but
we have a really big team we have some
here cool thank you ours thank you yeah
you guys are in a grinding business
totally I have a lot of respect for
people that work in restaurants a lot a
good time my brother lives in Arizona
see I was right you're the order for
tomorrow and my brother had me upset to
hear can be here I love it I'm glad you
came and I was cool how are you take a
punch
accordion of course about what the
locations great school I think it's a
half ago so hackable providing for hack
right to the throwing Times Square like
I got all everything and like a hundred
other people like I have no clue heart
watch my stories
100% please go ahead plugging all your
[ __ ] just random people just comics like
this is the summary message example yeah
for short
this entire hi how do I do anything come
on I came to talk to you about help you
boy I think sound engineers yeah
that's the better part that's the better
place I know that's my baby
it's like I'm like six degrees of
separation and I make my job here I call
no problems that I go and I just laugh
thank you Oh [ __ ] out Omega neither
please I don't with a baby I got this
baby
okay okay yeah yeah
thank you so much that's nice you think
you're ready created you for a long time
yeah yeah yeah man's occupation anyway I
won't go anywhere overpower me
Hospital of course thanks for coming
give someone your time ladies pardon
Karenina yeah I think about it I'd like
to hear one yeah yeah we met a year ago
and Prada coming me focus I couldn't
make it
you gave him this shout out young man
and so her that's you saying why the
[ __ ] on you be I love a man and we had a
Chinese coming to come in from the New
York but he's got us you know here yeah
yeah sick and shout I like why the [ __ ]
are you here
what's his name richard Bennett richard
ii six months listen I want you to
picture both of us Richard Gary be got a
very simple question
one of [ __ ] aren't you here haha sorry
buddy
yeah thank you coming you can tell Ian
thank you for doing what you do of
course going to help me out a lot what
if we have enough things coming out and
saying love your Lea but yeah of course
super dumb ass know how you got a shirt
the users working in the bouncer also
shirt to give away the pillow okay so
got the pillow holding it right you got
you got the power with the pillow
okay go to Denny's real quick
independent filmmaker right here I did a
show from that came out on Amazon solid
members up drop laws did he does it drop
us when did we get to this thing what
help us with marketing how cell count
out this is like make sure you a check
up receiver climb got to see it down no
I can't I can show it to you right now
but you know I got a really how long is
it like 60 seconds how bad is that
the first of the popcorn girl you know
the second thing that we did a card I
have a hammer
you know what I what you know wandering
shouting out receiver course she'll make
somebody pick you take them for real
quick yeah shouting I want perceivable
caution my independent show from
Neverland how long is that a bill what
does short film yeah it's 30 minutes or
30 minute show but i but i don't shout
out [ __ ] I got a free time I am
fulfilling a common event perfectly its
carry a vaynermedia I don't have a car
it's Gary Katz I I got I got like a
start-up idea to as well.did I'm from
I'm trying to fit up as well so I'm
going to get it within this okay some of
my wife here problem what girls are here
together
oh no work I was in the yard or you can
delete except I was gonna do it on the
oh I need not really report no I wasn't
making you an incentive evolution take
care we flew out five days ago for an
internship this summer I'm conniving one
way year is cool and in fact in your two
blogs my doorman I love them in
Melbourne I hate here communication
in other ways as well you can hear you
say malaria Marlo this is the best if
you launch our product or brand with the
best reading logs in Rand I'm actually
in the mail for nursery so we're kind of
very you know I'm doing whatever I'm
doing I'm we're holding I know but we're
coming up with like a tan tiny okay
we're going to relaunch in a couple
months which is basically want to know
which that's way of relaunching
something or rethinking how I mean to
come first even it comes down some
branding salesmen together they need to
think about your sales funnel you guys
think about your branding strategy you
know from a sales strategy it's all the
digital marketing you know Facebook ads
and Google Ads and signals and all that
right so a brand standpoint that's where
you get into like long-form content
based for commercials
influencers like events like there's no
[ __ ] magic [ __ ] there's nobody I'm
not even as good as I am at what I am
there's no answer to that question right
there's just the execution of the only
two things that sell [ __ ] which is
either build a brand or you're good at
sales right and you've got to do them
both in parallel because a lot of times
you don't do sales you don't get to the
brand and if you don't do the brand you
lose we're maple and all these things
where they lose is they're all such
hardcore digital marketers right all
they do is sales it's all conversion
based marketing it's CAC LTV it's you
know app downloads convert you know
email conversions they don't think about
the brand
all I do is brand all I do is brand
content value content value concept
value and that's why I win because I'm
I'm putting my brand top-of-mind that
inspires people to want to come out
people don't come out like this if
you're not bringing them value okay
people don't come out like this if
you're in sales right you're in sales
like I'm trying to extract money from
you people come out for this on brand
the way we buy stuff everybody here is
wearing [ __ ] that they don't even
realize why they bought it they bought
it as a brand so I would tell you to
focus much on brand as you can but not
get too far away from sales because if
you don't make it to brain so you got to
figure out your Kanan what about
products packaging pounds
runners and what you [ __ ] self right
but not as much if product packaging
can't hold you back
it's not going to be in the business
you're in the thing that set you over to
talk like a nicer container a white
thing like like the food quality is
something that can set where the power
is
if your food the problem is is if you
look at the history of like quick serve
or restaurants or food there have some
such an incremental jump for the food to
be tobacker so everything has to be good
enough right and just consistent
consisting of the yoga yeah me thank you
appreciate it my pleasure thank you
coming hi hi go man how are you good a
person for you so I'm putting a movement
of young people sanitary create
transformational change or the solution
yeah a lot of over had to do straight
like a purple culture and helpful brand
will actually wrote a cool animal
something there's a cosmetically
Millennials yeah or shape resonance
around the girls
so that's partially kind of like our
approach but what do you think is I
guess like the magical games of free sex
dreams for retail which pain it is
double which but actually primitive
movement
so I'm we're going to do this great lake
is like people face kind of constituency
again social where yeah really but you
catch the candidate with your multiple
cannon so important the candidate what I
mean by the my answer is consistent cuz
no political party or any movement is
going to have any momentum without the
singular person that builds the momentum
around you can go and find 17 candidates
community leaders it's the individual
percent that galvanizes the movements
that almost always historically how
humans work yeah got it so what I would
do is expand the videos of just like a
function you're exposing storytelling on
the Internet it felt like all those
candidates at once and have them all in
one place in one kind of way movement
based home where it should like they can
all share their brand in their vision
I like Tripp put that all in one place
so like on the internet other people can
access it I think those are still thing
my opinion same which is cool you're
going to find 39 people it's going to be
that what Sally is going to be the one
that actually makes the whole thing work
yeah you got to find the person yeah the
person that creates the waterfall for
the other you can have eight thousand
candidates in this party on a platform
yeah on the Internet but until you have
the candidate it's all just going to be
very small me nothing if you look at the
history of like parties and administer
hair
so you do your thing but just keep my
voice in about your mind that what
you're really looking for is the [ __ ]
purple every movement sign a single a
person even though even though hundreds
of people thousands people may share
that idea yeah
that would mean like if you actually
want to not be the see shade that have
happened in this country 50 years of the
cliche since 1960 young people that look
like you say we're going to do this
thing and it happens it doesn't happen
because it starts so ideological about
all of us it doesn't understand that in
evil but Raghavan was like like that I
mean came in any like quick steps of
progressive he would have said he took
it with him
so now we're left with nothing here no
he had a bit on the back because his
legacy is incredible thing and like I
you know we're truck palatable guy and
we're left with the progressive movement
because they're kind of late already and
our infrastructure and people have a
sound ballad you know like it's been
like totally like that and it should
work popular party yet we're like
committing election last one of my
generation soccer you lost election we
all suspected every level god oh yeah of
course because it's a swing back to what
happened when you were winning all the
electric that's the way is have in this
country for 300 years
yeah
I understand like it's like what does it
really mean like what's the counter
moves I think people get way too high
and low in a same way when he won eight
years ago I was like this is going to be
good it's just I have a way humans work
yeah nice work this thing that's
happening to the party routes not really
as best a weekly sort of election people
were saying with the Republican Party is
this really funny but I worked on my
Christmas campaign yeah I could ask that
okay and I watched it yep I watched in
real time yeah and say hi hi great you
know so I was no confusion a big boy
exactly that was really thinking like
yeah I know but you can never win
anything on visa yeah it was cure
defense yeah it was completely a blind
thought that the other guy was going to
put himself out of it yeah that's the
quickest way to lose yeah here's what I
would say okay to answer your question
it's the candidate Barack Obama would
have been perfect because he's one of
those kind of charismatic selfish legacy
people that can do a whole thing but if
you're going to do in a third party it's
got to be a human being it's gonna have
to be the person that carries that torch
so while you build platform and the
internet' miss keep that in mind because
that's how it actually works
yeah I'm just proving in all societies
across human race the last [ __ ]
thousand years it's what we do like we
don't remember what what Gandhi and
Martin Luther King and Barack Obama
Jonica and they're they're not the only
person that thought that a third a
person that dragged it yes anything
about my Christina but you're creating a
course yeah look it's the advice I'm
giving you now yeah II understand does
it actually do yes that's the answer no
that's always we have people movement
beneath the leader but the leader is the
leader lies non-commercial I'm not I'm
not the person that invented or or like
created like pure honest
entrepreneurship
yeah I'm just a person sadhus got it a
guy I really appreciate it good luck
thank you
yeah okay video and it kind of really
maybe heard out what I want to do with
my life I hope it has both Holloman my
hopefully I won't want the president
what we have annual thing you have a do
don't hit create all six music Rd like a
political morning that all these equal
human populations of oil in every action
every event has no responsibility
and we will get entire generation
government yeah on the bed recovering
for god sake this whole old on that's a
beautiful beautiful hey man I'll go I'll
vote for you
[ __ ] yeah yeah bro you are leading the
2050 oh by the way you got to be a
little selfish here I would love to work
I said for 100 hours on comes down the
possible just to make one or maybe I
like an email Gary Gary man we have to
thank you Tom
awesome thanks come on thank you I'm
sorry too man nice to meet you first
I really want to say thank you so much
for all the all the real [ __ ] that you
put out there because I feel there's a
lot of people that put on a lot of
things that are just trying to sell you
[ __ ]
yeah their master and online commerce
yes so miss you and I've gotten cut off
to that on athlean like yeah it sucks
you know and you're so real there's no
like ulterior motives you just want to
help people in like show people the
right way to do things that hi that's
how you win bigger I know and that's
that's why you get this you know you
don't have a ton of people behind you
like hating on you you're you're real I
wanted a thank you thank you Bob and
good question so ever as I have
immigrant parents I happy I got you
later I kind of old and how do you
balance like not letting down and do
your thing kind of how do you take care
of them without like doing something
stupid for money like something like
like quick cash you know what I mean a
hundred percent I know so I think the
question becomes how much like I think
that's a different kind of conversation
the app with them which is ever taking
care of people is all relative right so
like everybody everybody that lives in
this everybody that's in New York City
right the second has a very different
point of view of being taken care of
then the people that iraq and i saw in
ghana yeah
right like so I think the point to me
the question is what is being taken care
of like so let's make like being taken
care of is not like I'm going to buy my
mom's a really nice car be like like so
I think the question is do they want you
to take care of them what are they
expecting from you or is this some
romantic thing that you've created for
yourself that's where it starts a little
both like whether they you know like my
mom like super old you can't work right
and solemn with my dad and right I just
want to make sure that they have a place
to live right so I think I think the
question becomes like there's only two
ways to make money the right way in the
wrong way and so your talent on making
money the right way is going to
predicate how fast you can pull it off
there's no there's no match good you're
asking a binary question like hey how do
I not come up with spamming [ __ ] or do
quick rash stuff but even though I want
to do the spammy ship because if I make
twenty eight thousand dollars that can
mean something for my parents that's a
question if to make look you're talking
to somebody who thinks it's appropriate
to feel if you're homeless right like I
understand the logic so like when I tell
people like don't do dumb [ __ ]
that's like hey don't do only rip people
off so you can get a Lamborghini right
if you feel like not the best about what
you do but the sole purpose is it's
something you have to do right now
because your parents are getting evicted
who the [ __ ] am i to judge right so like
I think that's the calibration you've
got you've got to figure out how serious
is it because the longer you can wait to
do the right thing always the better
then they come back you're welcome in
social coming in group you go see the
picture girls
all right appreciate everyone makes out
to very much Andrew what does it do
no yeah I have more sex coming so Gary
how are you oh good much more than
course man we're like [ __ ] fire in
the morning man I think you get a
picture today awesome thanks so much
come on softly oh yeah thank oh we're
going to pursue my garden on underneath
thank you guys really over here driving
like a maniac I can get here in fact I'm
glad we need it yeah
the gadget use mimic that keep people
are tweeting like oh [ __ ] I'm in
Brooklyn I bought it a twenty like taken
a tornado made no dick just taken up at
8:20 because I'm exhausted
yes when all right and I'd snap telling
the guys do this I just jumped in I love
a man smoking the gadget Museum calm the
gadget museum is a museum and filling
tracking a lot of Tours but it's free
the point is is market research for the
inventors understood so my question is
how much do you think I can charge per
month or contract for an inventor to get
all that tracks from poor isms into that
score like South Street who knows like a
really I know it well so because my the
game is is market research that's what
I'm selling everything else is free do
you have no do you have any feel for
what the research is worth have you sold
it to anybody no I just got the place
I'm going to the convention with
Pittsburgh on Tuesday to just I would I
would walk into that convention as if
you already have the report or like the
data and like prices differently to
every single person like I you don't
know yet or ask at first because I was
kind of odd I don't think asking people
like hey how much would you pay for this
is the right strategy I think the right
strategy is running the gamut and be
like hey I've got this before for $1000
hey I've got this for four for five
thousand dollars hey I've got their
support for $10,000 I mean they put they
put their invention in the store
and over the long term people watching
how they interact with it there's a 360
can I get it it's valuable right very
value I just don't know how much it's
worth
okay and I'm giving you a really
practical answer for you to figure out
how much it's worried about like go to
that clip you go into the stoppers if
it's right
literally I would go to every single
person don't ask them how much they
would pay for it tell them how much it
is and then taste the reaction of the
first 30 people and then now on the
third and first person you know what the
charge like hey it's $500 cool I'll take
it
cool hey it's $8,000 know hey it's four
thousand one thousand two hundred bucks
hey-oh 500k it's five hundred knows too
much hey it's five hundred know too much
[ __ ] was it five hundred to that guy
over peg got it and in the time till
then focus on all the value right to
that crap like mad [ __ ] out yeah right
[Music]
thank you so much thank you I just
wanted to come in and see how much we
can we can push it over minute
everything I'm like either killing it
and you're like like provoking us all to
kill it well I love you thank you so
much for coming out bro what's up how
are you of course
how are you good like it's not gotta
live in the Kanekalon it yeah um you're
killing it ever
we ever Instagram cute videos me rocks
bulky killing it I want to know what's
interesting and I can't sleep in here
but I do know you only know you watch
the progression happen like overnight I
woke up you write a million on Instagram
yes like and now you're it's across the
board you don't need to focus
it's so obvious but it's been like that
forever I just wanna know you're hot
take on midpoint etherium blockchain so
in theory um's got to just side so I
think everybody knows I don't talk about
[ __ ] I don't know
and I'm even though I was three South by
of those but nine hours sitting in a
room talking about a period where was a
dollar fifty right I still know that
there are so many people that know so
much more here's what I would say it
can't lose over time so I don't know how
that manifests but it's binary the
blocks of its binary it's going to work
overtime here's what I don't know by not
playing is good enough by not doing
enough homework
the reason I'm not putting out content
is here the things that I don't know I
don't know how I think because I haven't
done homework on what governments do it
out because there are big I know a cute
big companies are much smaller than
government right so so I don't know that
I don't know I don't know enough the
reason I love aetherium is because what
that is is it's so much more agnostic
than currency that's us doing these
deals with each other it's way beyond
that so I understand that why it will
work I just don't know enough of the
details that I like you guys know you
guys know how I talk about social and
content and marketing that feels and
tastes and sounds different than
everybody else because I so know it so
overall when I'm asked on the record I
think it's going to work to play the
game I'm going to play the game yes I
bought I bought it but to get the way
for me to play the game is there you
know what I'm glad you brought up
Instagram I've been on Instagram for
five six seven years right like I'm
Rebecca so 18 months
24 18 and 24 months ago I had 84
thousand followers on Instagram it was
it was completely secondary thought to
me then I decided to play with it a
little bit and that's why I got the 400
and ended December member alert I
remember I just looked at them like you
know what I'm gonna go very serious at
this so probably at some point March
them next year I'm like you know what
[ __ ] this I'm going to get very serious
about Chris out and like and think about
it so calmly okay I want you to look
pretty good for me yeah I'm really using
snapchat I know okay so just say no
could be Mike just so you guys know
straight up like like segment statement
of the night in snapchat ads are
massively underpriced they're $2 $3 CPM
and you can swipe up and get long-form
content literally tomorrow I'm running
heavy I'm about to get very serious
about snapchat very it's just it's just
you notice it like there's still an
ungodly amount of [ __ ] people
consuming snapchat I don't know good
thing I know is we talk about a 20.2
instagrams gonna be around for sure
of course cuz they smoke so good yeah I
think they're too much money they're not
going to talk about the 2022 but we
could be talking about like tumblr have
you done anything right in six years
it's still here right exactly but it
hasn't done anything right in fact
explain it so what I mean by that money
caption yes and no the market Springs
favorite state independent they would
have raised so much money that they'd
still be around so yeah but he's not
David is the last person should we worry
about yeah so I think we'll be around
but I'm not worried you know that I'm
not worried about that I'm worried about
right this minute and right this minute
because of instagrams copy features so
many people gun so far into Instagram
only while there's still just enormous
amount of action on snapchat and now
they have an ad product that's
interstitial that if you understand how
to make content well you can buy for $2
CPM
that people get what
are we gonna make it add I decided burn
apart from myself and it's just a mess
it's going to be like you [ __ ] suck
and I'm going to show you how to fix it
and sometimes I think like just wipe up
and then I'll go into a longer form
video I just think it's gonna work I
think people can be considered in
government we Nouri between stores we
choose our imagination that way seems
like it I got some genius does anybody
in here just kind of course on snapchat
all in say hello
oh my oh we like it right here come bro
keep it very good together all right
okay oh yeah okay so six long months ago
I met Jason Bogard we're cleaning before
I hit him up I was like you but media
company like what that's a spectacle I
work for Derek what oh my god
you used up on me with my life upside
down I quit my job
six figures because of what you said
where how would you make your money is
much more important than how much you
make and it has I grew everything that's
happened to me I am just so much more
fulfilled and I understand all the
things that I don't want in life which
is way more important than the other
thing believe or not yeah like it didn't
matter that my bank account was looking
good because I felt like I was lying at
the floor and taking it and it didn't
matter
Ryan he was like you think that for me
with Papa to fix big pulses we do that
right I would like to know do you think
you thank you so much and if there's I'm
in touch with Jason but if there's any
other way I just actually gave him a
spot I'm sorry at this convention in st.
John for the Diageo chair which was
really cool awesome if there's any other
way that I can just give something else
I'm saying to everybody at scary of
vaynermedia it's the only chance my
sliding into my DMS is long over like
you know
winner is the one place I think you guys
see it I'll interact because I just look
at it conflict that's where you can get
that's where you get a thanks or a like
if you're like a hey or like a yes or no
but my emails be only emails when I
yesterday I had a promote like on that
12-hour flight yesterday I had to
promote the show and so I did that
but that would have been high where I
would but but females of one place felt
like I save them like I emailed by the
way I emailed some of the other day for
my 2007 it was like save them I got this
one folder like so it's the one place
you can get an answer later
thank you so much thank you yeah of
course forget itself of course yeah II
had a t-shirt saw you want to flash here
give us 5 thanks thank you meant so much
you're welcome sugar hi man 3 especially
to I love you bro thank you visit
obviously I have these two small
businesses they make a busting at social
media in a shoe putting this is I got to
get today from you and how do I go then
act like hot dog I get people with me I
get that a thousand a month yep so I'm
like stuff how long have you been doing
them like like a year now
yeah so I can't get through that for the
social media got an agency I have a I
have a PI right now and that's what for
is the carpentry business yep and he
does good at like he gets good results
and it's all you do are you going to
school till I go to school so I mean I
think I think couple things like it I
don't I work you know I think it's
important to make sure you know where
you are in the process so like it's
interesting like when I was making like
$4,000 a weekend selling baseball cards
I didn't think it was a business I think
I was making money I think everybody you
know you know how I talked about
everybody wants to be entrepreneurs it
looks like you have a client that's very
different to have a business I mean how
do you how do you fix that plateau you
spend all your time knocking on small
business to like the whole young kid
social media business thing is very
honorable think of small businesses when
they don't get click ROI fire people so
you get a client right you get a client
for five hundred bucks or thousands it
feels good it looks like it's gonna be
good
they get fired after three months like
it's very easy to build your social
media business you go knock on every
small business store virtually or in
real life and you get more clients and
then you like figure out what they need
like it's not super complicated it just
takes a fuckload of time and like and
you have to know what you're doing when
people pay you a thousand dollars they
want something to happen almost every
kid that I know especially as people are
like selling the idea of like everybody
should have their own social media
agency it's really good for the person
that sells the model of everybody should
build a social media agency it's not as
good for the people that actually have
to go out and build a social media
agency and then can't like build it like
you start getting a thousand you start
getting a thousand dollars for a piece
of shop and they think you're going to
do something and you talk a big [ __ ]
game because all you have is sizzle like
what are you doing for that Val's about
here the drivers old yeah and so so that
one's a very difficult business I'm I
have a client service business that
one's hard the shoe flipping business is
again very unscalable business unless
you're paying off people at scale that
can like stand in lines or get or get
things behind the strains or like like
imposing like it looks before t seem to
get paid yeah I see you know so I mean I
would say for me if I heard this
scenario I would first say like why are
you going to school what are you looking
to get out of that is that just trying
to make your parents happy like you got
a lot of answers I use it as a like
because like a clutch like if I fail
yeah yeah I have my site
yeah but I don't have to be enough
concert I get it and I talk no I mean I
think I think I think I think it's just
early so like I don't think you've
plateaued because you haven't been doing
it long enough to know that you've
plateaued like Plateau is consistent off
of base of growth a consistent stagnant
situation you haven't even you're just
like you're just started feeling
plateaued you're trying to you're you're
you're you're doing three things which
means you're doing no things so right so
it's hard it's hard to like figure that
out I think you'll go the other way one
of things you could do that I'm giving
this advice to everybody is people go do
ten more things one of the things that
this young of an age is you know for you
to consider to try six other things at
the same token because now you're just
tasting [ __ ] yes and and we might be
able to figure out what you actually
wanna do so if you actually ask me I'd
far rather everybody under 25 here do
eleven things instead of one thing
because they might get a better sense of
what's a good at what they love most hmm
thanks for coming right yeah she's
coming
Kisuke
I got it oh yeah
it's a Thomas J my traditional hi
Tiffani fantasy right yeah picture baby
names I really appreciate your head I
really appreciate your love I know that
not a thing to come in process yeah like
I was very loving your pet I do
I just thank you for all the work you do
Gabe you plan your coming and yet right
here anyway that sharp election coming
oh my god thank you like I quit my job
last year because of you that's been
doing that's amazing right I feel so
much better like I went to college for
my parents that's got this job for my
parents and now it's like a now it's
time for me and cuz I'm 25 I'm like I
can mess it up like you always say that
yeah now I'm doing that but it the thing
is like okay you keep on coming like a
little yeah but yeah hey get a job you
need to go get it from your great dad to
be like I don't want to end up like you
and be miserable I'm a mother seems like
when much my parents I'm being serious
with my parents with my wife when my
friends so jabs at me I throw jabs back
I found like there's nobody who's
undefeated there's nobody who surely got
everything right yeah like I just
checked those people challenged me and
challenged them back because that's that
gives you the air cover for them it's a
funny thing happens when people throw
jabs are you and things are you when you
start doing it to them
they tend to slow down they're just on
the offense
right yeah how cool love they're just
doing it because that's what they
believe it
but if that's not what you want you need
to establish your ground and the best
way to do that this is just jab them
back okay no it's not for me like
everything I need to do like what we
want like he loves you luckily you
should be doing and it's like so hard
you twit I'm using guns that back yeah
you're 25 okay be like be like tell them
no longer you want me to come over
mom dad [ __ ] you 17 yeah no I'm
graduating high school - yes I'm beating
you your eyes maybe we have like 10
terrific
what would you describe us I would do
whatever [ __ ] I would whatever I was
into at that time I I think the best
thing to do is build [ __ ] around your
into what you're into so I look at the
things you actually give a [ __ ] about do
it yes there's so much better you know
the cliche thing but it's better like if
you're going to work 18 hours a day and
if you're going to take high risk and if
you live in a shitty place and if you're
not going to like it's far better so I
do it around things like we've just got
to be make sure that you don't get high
off your own supply yeah you got to make
sure that you don't go into music
because what you want to do is just the
rappers and go to concerts not actually
build a business so the danger of like
doing what you love is that you love it
and you're actually not trying to build
a business you just want to hang around
with those people it's why people lose
and sports businesses and music
businesses so often they don't actually
want to build a business they just want
to shake Jeter's hand or being backstage
with drink right so I think I think that
uh if you can do it around something you
love but you actually trying to build a
business yeah
not get seduced by bad things that's
normally the motto
yeah want to get away me shot you here
yeah alright good
sup Gary hi hi I'm Camilla I'm from
Edison loved it there ignore that isn't
I went to save receiver I would have
wanted Jamie Stevens but I read and you
want to edit that I know I know I moved
100 and county like far away I would
want to JP I went to John Adams middle
school oh my god I went to Woodrow and I
played baseball was your Wilson and I
went to Martin Luther King Elementary so
hey I was on the other side of town I
would say would run I love it and now
I'm a female urban farmer out of
Brooklyn and I want to show you my farm
we ship we farm out of shipping
containers I love it and so I'm part of
like an entrepreneurship and urban
farming you like your own post I feel
like I like oh that was gonna be a
problem of like I [ __ ] love me I feel
like but yeah so I wanted to invite you
because this is like an entrepreneur
incubator and some farmers were in
Brooklyn and oh yeah swear words girl
and also farming it up because I'm a
vertical farming farming it up farming
up yeah farming it up send me an email
with ubicool yeah and I'm trying to like
build a brand
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you thanks Gary Gary Vee what's
going on man Zoe nice to enjoy I just
was watching your videos it's more tie
broke my foot whooping I love and I kind
of let myself go a little day watching
your video
Shelby V yeah it's like you just gotta
be a hundred percent in on everything
and just fine every successful romance I
was watching that it really got me going
Comanche I also want to say really level
your deal with the theater sports
thank you I graduated law school last
year and wanted to be an agents in some
paths you know you guys are still small
yet working as an agent or a sports
broadcaster ability and they have the
totally same mindset that you ever
inner sports just not not business
partnerships with personal relationships
to decline I love it man so I call I
take a quick picture with York thanks so
much I really appreciate it
pretty good and just my card my resume I
know I think he's really appreciate your
talking to our president I think you
guys backstage sitting on it all right
nice a lot okay
hi we're all following that your dreams
without expecting anything similar to it
that we have here this is not a music
composer and study anywhere you and
because of you what I did linked up with
another guy yeah yeah because obvious so
thank you for that of course and I don't
have a cool the glamour trying to get
friends out here tonight and knowing
where to go choose mistake on our part
to go make you said okay well then watch
have to go right what's your name my tea
so much matter so sure remember what is
it mighty silly matter salt is that what
you said they marry have yeah nautical
friend just me Gary be I'm super [ __ ]
pissed at all of you but not know me the
[ __ ] I am
[Laughter]
cool got it thank you you're welcome
thanks me thanks for coming yeah thanks
for coming
cool came into my bedroom on Clinton
Club Bergen County I love it as you're
coming at all you're not recovering but
early Jersey I just have a quick
question man about friends and do you
feel like in order do you feel like they
really hold you back or do you feel like
you can be friends you thought you could
be friends with people who aren't I am i
yes I and I am and then it in effect you
correct because they're not my core
inner circle friends if you're poor if
you're poor inner circle friends are
sitting around playing mad and smoking
weed you're going to lose that's just a
hundred percent such as you don't ditch
them like when people when people you
know I made that one video like drop a
friend out of friends and got people
upset and I understand because I think I
could have done a better job at some of
the day every day all the time like I
might need to see you like every two
weeks and like it's good like everyone
needs down up top like I watch the Jets
like I sleep like people need to do [ __ ]
and that's maybe when you can hang out
with that friend but they can't be like
like it's just it doesn't work because
it's the people you spend time with are
the ones that dictate your mindset such
as 100%
okay see I think you got to think about
it of course if you were there in the
background be out there I know a lot of
you got the background wallpaper thank
you so much thank you coming up ago I
can't take it
how are you like that April Mary good
for you man go how's it going good good
first week yeah good timing
oh it's definitely different double yeah
yeah Oh Devon okay what's up you know
I've been there twice down the last nine
months I've been debating it I'm we're
in London and so like there's a lot of
Dublin's Amazings of Facebook and Google
and attacks even taxes just proximity
wise it's so close to what we've got
with London so I've got to figure it out
cravings very good thing yeah I'm
staring at
okay thank you yeah thank you do one
with flash - is that where she'll get
over it
I appreciate everything my luck thank
you guys a lot of it
thank you thank you yes Sean Sean how
are you just raised for everything thank
you for bringing all around here and
like for inspiring us later I'd like
this water I'm like yeah like everything
very knowledge I just want to watch it
you can thank you so much for our show
being able to be able to get here I
thought about finishing and I was like
yes thank you bing-bong yeah thank you
no thank you for doing that
pretty arc of course hell yeah I got you
that you would supplies black one
Thank You Kerry I appreciate that thank
you
Deshawn Sean real pleasure of your huge
inspiration first of all thank you get
that from everybody thank you um I got a
question for you so I spent the last two
years building up Instagram accounts for
startups and so I think I'm pretty good
at building up Instagram accounts know
how to start a business out of it I've
heard like affiliate marketing maybe but
I don't think you give me advice on what
to do about that place what you do what
I think you do with attention is you
deploy it against something right so I
think the reason I think losing my model
looks is I never think about like oh I'm
going to create a quick little Instagram
account and I'm going to sell shoutouts
against it like people cash in chips too
soon I think it's much better to build
up their two rim account and then push
it towards something that's meaningful
so it's in the same way I think about me
right like I put out content for their
content I and then you know I'll have
things to push it against like for
example I'll push against something like
plan of the apps right now I'll promote
all through ammo right hooks that that's
valuable for me because everybody at
Apple is like for what the [ __ ] like why
is Gary Vee thriving more success for us
than the other three real celebrities
and then that builds reputation I'm
playing on reputation I so I think
what's way cooler than then doing
affiliate marketing and making quick
pennies is saying yourself taking a step
back and saying what do I want to sell
is there anything I want to sell oh you
decide you want to sell backpacks
well then you start building up like
like urban street account you start
building a travel account you build
momentum and then when you post you're
driving into a nice Shopify page for a
nice bag and you're like actually
building something tangible doing
affiliate marketing on Instagram when
that's again it's the rams terms of
services when you're doing it on a
platform that has all the leverage and
not you it never works out everybody's
making quick dollars that way it doesn't
work so how much of a following should
you
start pushing a product if you have
three people following you and all three
convert and that's a good business see
what I mean
that's the answer alright it's a it's a
matrix of what you're in like when you
want to happen like if you want to sell
eight thousand dollars worth of stuff
because you want eight thousand dollars
to go on some cool trip and Cretan next
year
well you can start selling a lot earlier
you want to build a million dollar
business like latest [ __ ] build a real
foundation okay yeah yes sir thank you
for sure thank you Smith and if they
come out you should it's real nice to me
because when I always hang out with in
DVDs on corners know my mom pay your
rent I get it I just want to say thank
you also your college grant saved my
life I was graduating high school
eighteen just eight months ago wasn't
excited about college my family placed
this expectation told me that I needed
to go I decided not to bought a one-way
ticket to New York crashed on couches
now I have an apartment in Bay Ridge and
I just got a part-time job at Equinox to
start my personal training business next
week my pleasure at also make you glad
I'd love just to get a quick video for
my mom because I told her I'd meet you
before the year was over now that hey
mom just wanted to say oh yeah he did it
I'm not him before the year was over
made in winter York and next week I'm
starting at Equinox no lemon expand so
much come on thank you
it looks anarchic good boy go home now
you got to go you got early you're
different you got to wake up early
yeah hey how are you I love it so much
I don't give a go I got what I want to
make Berkeley Horrigan
what's up flogs you know this man is a
scaredy episode clip it right now dear
Raksha bigger man we're so proud of this
guy I won three everyone you know
everybody's got a free book I expect you
to leave a real review you I hate it you
let me know but if you got a free book
you better [ __ ] review it I don't get
right Josh I should leave no pleasure
man oh just wanted to say I brush down
here I got her Toby I was down here tell
me I have my friend I'm here by myself
I'm 23 years old I'm an autist myself
and I'm I saw him a shot gotta show for
you too thank you my man on my brand-new
string work huh - no we out here
dreaming we are we're working we
definitely have a husband I love it I
just want to say like you've definitely
motivated me like I definitely had to
come down here Mitch I don't know how
it's hard like it's all again next we
got no course minimal I did it hope I
get a drop on the on the only program
you already know what it is Owen that's
it we all here dreaming we all here
working we are we're hustling we are
here with Gary Vee
shout out to Charlemagne to God you know
all out here out here working you
already know what it is hustle
thank you very much Appalachia which of
course carry a hip was like a character
if that's a shirt regimented I hope I
got Josh Dobbs laughter god
okay thank you very much fun pleasure
man takes your coming out of it matter
I'm looking l think so hopefully I need
a pen come out that's right
that's not a taking he goes I carry
myself even better he has insurance on
the driver
instead I'm going to try to get through
everything I know you got a guy's way
earlier everybody get their book sign
I got my book time in my life I saw your
you're into video year goes it's copy in
the third job connections now what is
going to be Fallon amendment I make a
motion or something you know what's
funny that's an interesting video to me
it did well it did well I really wanna
I'm going to do it it's such a good
video good like it's such a good advice
really really my ideal I gotten some
really cool you know some people about
that one that's what you're supposed to
do after two hours but it has nothing to
do with learning everybody with learning
you should be useless yeah boy is a
commodity yeah mr. myko my leg diesel
like we're [ __ ] smart of the sound as
I think I am you're way better off
shaking each other's hands then you are
listening to what I'm going to say
you're going to hear it at some point
because I'm working with other interns
they really was read but I would stay on
elegant and so what happened and I was
invited to a Ghostbusters Romero's I
know this is pretty cool and it's like
there's people and get to know people
personally in like a you get offered
jobs and then and be so loving them
you're the man you're going Michaelson
mammal Miranda thank you guys
here let me go yeah I was like oh my god
it looks pretty legit
love it thank you gee I'm a slide I love
you love me too were listening hey makes
to think happy to do a job I'll talk to
you later
hey yeah hey Sean did you guys didn't
you guys hook up with Tyler what's going
on with all right quad motel hey you up
later
I don't you think I'm inspiring your
space boy you know obviously the
coalition haulers new flag planning a
new friend came with everybody on to my
mom
I'm originally from sort of part of us
or the appellate court in the bank right
now my mom is always sending me videos
I sent her home and or what i watch
tonight and so she asked me about a new
400 shine so my question is were there
we thought in terms of a higher power
and I was saying no religion you're
dividing it yeah big elongated we're you
know I'm funny because I'm in a unique
spot because Soviet nations have it very
weird because religion was persecuted in
communist Russia so there was no
religion in our country for 70 years
what I love is that there's this thing
that brings people so much value in the
heart is like and I know that if like if
I
my mom was walking right out and got hit
by car and died like the first places I
would go over like God please like you
like this thing right the thing that I
so honestly honestly very honestly I
don't think about it too much but not
from a pro or con right I don't judge
people on that I don't for myself
i'ma I was feeling I'd be massively
religious if I grew up in that
environment I think it just manifests in
a different way okay that would be my
answer okay oh great as you coming I
referred oh yeah by the way
come on leaders at work all of them have
hustled other on I love it so just
coming out
so mad how are in didn't feel our usual
good man skipper freedom caucus either
well are you guys not so I've seen a
bunch of the episodes ready when you
aren't in anything
oh I'm waiting there your child all
right it was the first leg I I'm alive
yeah yeah I'm gonna say hello
gonna see you guys stick around oh yeah
well yeah thanks canceled second seal is
one thing burn up yeah I'll be this time
already put on flashing everybody 31
anyone taking it up good these are as
long as we're here like cool am I gonna
feel good how you been I get oh well um
first that's what check out my deal
mMmmm I want to say thank you Garrity
Mountain City College you know it's so
nice after a lot you know a lot of
students life's changed because of that
so first can you force this video was it
not very possible no am people picky
around me yeah yeah I'm an immigrant
named when I was 11 years old mom and
where I grew up a lot of my homies grew
up really really poor yeah and they grew
up in the hood and they didn't know what
to do and a lot of them got stuck there
and stayed there because I was offered
opportunity I found mentors
I thought be able to look up to 2015
homie that you know what in the u.s.
when you okay so and I was lucky I found
mentors like my parents didn't know
anything oh it's a horrible high school
right and and so my question is this
first of all so this morning I had this
idea to start the one question show okay
I'm starting the show before one
but there's no better way to stop it
without a big hair can we also come love
together so my question
yeah it's practical you can get yes how
can you make it out of the hood
no matter your circumstances no matter
where you started by physically leaving
the hood
whether it's virtually or whether it's
actually physically meaning being stuck
in the hood is mental it's a mental game
like you can get to anybody in today's
world
I've document I mean we know how many
all of you know about my DM thesis it's
real you will get to end everybody you
get to anybody the problem is you have
to ask a thousand people that look like
that to get the lead to say yes but you
can get to anybody like like you could
just get anybody like anybody on any
given day can say yes I've got 10
minutes for you now the question is I'm
actually not even concerned about that
like kin in the deepest hood could get a
meeting with Puff Daddy tomorrow can get
a meeting with Warren Buffett tomorrow
that's real I know that to be true the
question is would he get asked and I
think the problem is most people ask for
something instead of trying to figure
out how to give something notice how the
interns is like you know I think he left
like like he said thank you for the
intern advice that helped me what he did
was he heard me which was give and work
hard and just say hello to people
everybody's asking for something I think
you're going to flip it so I would say
getting out of the hood is mental and
realized that you can and as long as you
have a cell phone and an Instagram
account you can be a 700 people in a day
and after a week of 4900 people getting
VM two of them are going to give you a
meeting go to those meetings so what
could they possibly give like this like
if I make it like I grew up a little bit
more I was luckier but what could they
get like what can I possibly tell you
like what could they possibly give us
not like when they came from nothing
like what can I do in sight you know
let's labor like like for they they give
somebody like me the ability to give
back to the game
it gives me a chance like what do you
think I'm doing like I'm always just
giving back to the game when you think
this is doesn't mean giving that to the
game that put me on the game that put me
on sorry
no thank you make sure like so so I
promise you that if some kid from like
hardcore Mississippi somehow somehow
catches Warren Buffett I in the DM and
and that kid goes and had that meeting
and his opening line for Warren Buffett
is I'm here to bring you values what can
I do for you
that in itself it's going to unlock the
opportunity 100% yeah thank you thank
you all I love it
how are ya vanity of multiple safety I
think everybody said one point one point
one point one point six yeah
pelagic six point one create yeah I had
a one point six I mean I had that report
card I put up on incident I got to get a
clean of her Tyler yeah I did I posted
on Instagram account like six or seven
months ago but I need a I need a better
one anyway sorry I'm not my report card
it's where is it oh I don't even know
not I don't have no I don't have that
you turned out just fine Tony that's how
we got my high school down like Tyler
email the hi Scott what you I told the
dollar you get it
I mean plus a high score top right
because I think the right answer is as
much of the advice I give I know this
right the reason I like doing this is if
I can give one-on-one advice it's always
going to be better because it's
contextual there's no blanket advice for
those 29 kids I think I think it's about
self-awareness the real answer is
somewhere the [ __ ] answers I like to
think when I people actually thought
that I make people like myself where
their thinking processes agree but it's
just so manager than that plan like it's
about knowing yourself and then coming
to grips with what everybody's
ideological about themselves which is
why they manifest into delusion or into
complaining like the reason everybody is
delusional about what they're going to
be and the reason there's going to
complain about everything is they don't
want to deal with the truth so what I'm
going to do with them you got to get
them to the truth you see the video I
made with the silly school kids I just
put it up there's a video I put up a
week ago I think it's up it's like all
these silly school kids but we did it
worked and all you're telling them a
truth really like they need you're
skeptical kids like the breakthrough
moment in that video is like the drug
dealer kid going oh [ __ ] like you know
like the only can't work for truth
the only thing that breaks through to
you for cetera it's helpful look but you
know but you're but here's the problem
with the tree even you who made this
effort to be here who clearly gets it
has to hedge about showing them my
content because there's closer
very well here principal you think I
promise you the [ __ ] hallway is way
worse than any of my videos but that's
super interesting right yeah like like
that's why teachers have a tough time
breaking through because I'm empathetic
to why you have to worry about that
because you don't want to deal with the
ramifications of it you're in a system
I gots why we've kids kids that were
doing it because they can't get the
truth you know what I mean like so for
me like like I have a much video has a
much better chance to break through this
kid the majority of stuff so I don't
know I don't know the right answer I'm
empathetic like honestly maybe
experience by tutoring in the outside of
school where you can then surely it's
about breaking the system it is I mean
I'm not I'm not mad at the system the
system works for some it just doesn't
like it's not not gonna break through
when you think oh [ __ ] I gotta break
through the heart that's hard you know
yes okay
Thank You Fang oh no what is it yeah I
don't want to
you need to download Apple music ask you
guys any data Mansell right everyone
uses you can watch the show Iraqis given
out I get closer my very good assignment
the music Africa open him years ago
don't worry very so now yeah yeah oh
yeah Sony with a mug in one myself
actually we do I'm actually see if you
can browse now some people don't agree
do I was like you know Jake I was very
excited yeah no exactly we're interested
I even was weird I'm going to run on
that okay hello that you look cooler or
you're moving so become kind of 120v
nation it's for a couple months and you
guys I keep looking out for the
California market it and then we do that
with Mexico then I'll just bust forth
speedily
eventually rule to Barbados to make up
my man launch I go on and then a couple
days ago barbatus just come up with a
plan
and was like when we commenced in the
art of the old phone and then no I was
seriously two days after you said I was
like I don't know it's exciting like
this all day I would say to myself and
I'm kind of shaking right now saying how
crazy would it be if when I get New York
any other manager yeah so we're day we
go to go to beat Aurelius yeah I saw
that today as I hop I did pop queen
so there's to change that like I want to
say they particle morbidity vocoder
dynamic couple super fittest Edison
concentrating second I'm amazed how
queer doing hip-hop you say and holiday
that something right unheard of yeah I
put all of you know thinking for a
community everything is against me
sure always up myself like if a district
business is offering that I don't sleep
exactly on the same website I don't
think I'm not really good but I was
doing it myself just crime in it hey
Callie and so to be here in help is
different supersanic supersanic
lyrically so you think I would really
although evidently you're also discussed
how y'all feeling however in addition to
what you're doing
why how different in the house a
majority in music why would we examine
that you find important so many male we
will want to me our union are you now
going to be very long I'm leaving okay
it pretty tough because I'm leaving to
LA for all the show sucks but I'm sure
like we live in Barbados okay that's
ability on that okay we'll figure it out
we're going to figure it out okay my man
how are you close what's that having
okay here's the head you came out here I
can't you all new here give me one
second any well ii got you you know
thanks often us thank you so much that's
make it I'm glad you're here
makes me feel happiness creepy yeah a
husband a wife and a kid I gotta head
out okay cosmic give me one second of
your banner and once I don't everybody
stay in the same spot like three times
tell there's something all right Lori
are you thinking little one out sorry
made you stay out so late
I know thanks so much thank you for
coming yeah okay all right okay thank
you we're gonna do picture of Spencer
sweet dare you got one minute uncle
swinging here okay sighs you've got to
get some blood for DJ Clue the [ __ ]
man right here there's got a little beep
going better than that
[Music]
I can't believe you guys came out here
don't you think subdued okay I'll even
do 5 May for happiness you have a friend
Brad Carlotta he works for you I just
wanted to ask you do a favor and just
say a quick shout out he works real hard
9:00 p.m. on the studio for you yep
perhaps I know that sure of course
Reb I don't know why we have to do this
through the video just [ __ ] seven
emails have meaning my mother
quick question how do you keep up the
energy like I was getting tired after
work but you're here and I you know it's
gratitude gratitude gratitude from
coughing trumps everything grit like
either you're grateful for all this or
you're not
not super complicated just got to be
thankful like people just people just
don't have perspective it's really easy
to be energized when you actually
understand the score you get real happy
real fast
people just get dragged down to jump
[ __ ] sure what's up Tim for you hey
charges everything with rampage fit make
it work oh let me just can't believe it
yeah that's my wish - oh my god oh wow I
know you're hustling well Tyler centers
the view they were trying to get forget
it forget forget I'm never going that
will make you sure yes it's 11:11 and
I'm a Gary so it's pretty little head
out you are thank you so much can we
pump it up here hustle thank oh yeah
value
any chance that you would ever even work
for free I'm considering new york
starting my modeling where do we live
Harford County Maryland Arobin are
you've heard some you emailed me so
Jerry will they know
lots of my seniors across thank you
thanks Kelly clementa Gary all heard me
man
thank you Joe city from Atlanta Georgia
I was in State University majoring in
engineering and I was like I got really
tired it was frustrated doing same thing
every day so I recently moved to here
and I became an EMT and like my parents
always tell me like wants to be an
engineer dogs do something like that and
I'm meeting the doctors and I'm meeting
everybody there's surgeons and they're
like it's like the wire wheel just gets
bigger and bigger and bigger everybody's
still trying to taste like that
financial goal or whatever but I just
realized that it just gets worse like
the wheel just gets bigger 100% and how
do I just want to like get to the point
in my life where my time is my own and I
still like to do what I feel like I want
to do you know what I mean I just want
to get to be able afford that yeah and
be exactly be able to poised to be the
captain of my own vessel done saying of
course engines and I also know that
you're like 20 to 3 and 20 to 25 just
I'm 20
you know like you know we were trapped
in their vessel predicated on how much
money you have and how much money it
cost to operate your vessel so what you
know you got to figure out how you're
going to do that like if there's no like
you got to figure out how to make money
or you got to figure out how to live a
life that makes you happy that's gonna
cost a lot of money like it's just a
chess balance there's people make two
million dollars a year back to work
every day because they spend 1.9 million
on their overhead
their rent their car they're like like
it's about you're running a personal P&L
so if you really care about doing what
you want to do and that makes you happy
we'll try to figure out how to do that
for $50,000 a year it's like you don't
need to own a home no need to you can
read like people are just making
decisions the cat that put them in a
tough spot so running your vessel you
can do right now if you're willing to
[ __ ] really really live it humble
like if you're working for somebody
you're not running your own vessel yeah
exactly and that means you're at the
expense of that captain and that's fine
especially when you're [ __ ] 20
because you can eat that [ __ ] for 5 10
15 years you just don't know how young
35 is that's all that's the biggest
compro you just don't know how young 35
is don't know right how old are you my
man right can you believe how young you
feel it's just crazy like the only
reason you're impatient are trying to
figure out tomorrow is just don't know
how young 35 feels because I know one
thing when I graduated from school at 22
my cousin Bobby worked in the store he
was 30 I thought he was old as [ __ ] so
when you're 20 and you hear a [ __ ] 35
that feels like [ __ ] old I know what
that feels like
I remember it still doesn't mean it's
not true and that just changes
everything
because when you realize that 30 like
it's the best way for you to run your
own vessel at 30 is to eat [ __ ] from 20
to 30
Oh
so I gotta figure out how you want to
navigate that exception yes thank you
very much number game I got everything
else
thank you big Christmas below II mean
thanks man awesome I think think I do
prison they take how much are you
impatient I'm on soccer you know I don't
rustle yes I remember I really yeah very
good for the senior yeah I mean I know
that one that I go to the public - oh
yeah right you know people and I came in
I remember fall I never was color and
the guy's a real remember let me tell
you about that and you know we were
talking I like connecting go from that
in a day
I call the game on screen how can we
provide much more value you know I
talking that I stairs I would add
another thing I really like there is not
forget it all right I don't mind about
my you know guys who you know either
Bader
for matter the audience right now I
excited we listen to New York and
Needham I'm gonna be entirely on the
technology guys I want to be old
yeah my way that I get it I can advance
it I get any people Tommy hey the total
thing I know one I'm felicity
yeah and I know whatever they say oh one
second he was so nervous
so whatever beautifully in the water
yeah I don't want I know to you I
there's nothing significant that I want
to build right now it from an
engineering standpoint it's just now
where my head's at so I don't I don't
nothing comes to mind that's what's
really wanting to a mind like mine you
need for engineering talent is very low
I have too many engineers of a doc you
know what I mean so but anyway the idea
was like nothing is not even simply
reduce looking like Jay whatever thing
but to provide the value of people
thinking about hey the complete duration
for whatever you want I don't think I
think that's a boring argument okay I
think that I don't think I don't think
anybody's smart believe that I think
you're in the bubble of Tech Talk I got
ya I thought about it's not something I
even think about is real right
it's not right now is the best
engineering talent in Silicon Valley I
rap yeah that's where they go you know
it's like it's like if you want to be in
movies they're in LA
like that's where it is like if you want
to like if you want to be like hardcore
like like if you want to like break out
in current hip-hop like Atlanta is
probably a good place to be but it
doesn't even can't be somewhere else
like I have no passion Iran to prove
that New York or New Jersey or Arkansas
or Atlanta is it the next good tech hub
because I mean I think it's going to
happen
Texas agnostic like it's everywhere like
it I don't even sex that's a boring for
me 2009 conversation that was fun when I
read TechCrunch every day that doesn't
mean anything to me anymore no no I
guess yeah you know
yeah moment I love that good to see you
again I do remember that as a black baby
was I just given it yeah of course
thanks for coming out loud together
Thank You operator
hey how are you Marcus always show it in
Vietnam like I could do that with scale
the open map getting better my
boundaries are Davin Saracens apartment
much especially helping verify apart
from other people early from engine -
yeah the work we're creating like very
much
yeah like the work with clients saying
you're good is what matters getting
clients means nothing keeping clients
and having them get you other places how
you build an economy the Buddha's
problem with that whole movement to all
these agencies is the size of the
clients are small and you guys are going
to go to big turn what are you charging
time there was asking our why you're
gonna lose that so is everybody else
so how long have you had the longest
morning oh my god - it very much yeah
you're deep [ __ ]
I mean a crash everybody's in trouble so
what should we give you that make $4,000
mean something okay yeah
is it all working out all right let's
get in restaurants like myself to more
so and I love our dad real if you
thought like that's the only thing you
should be spending time on person are
farming always deep hunter and everybody
is just hunted like like I would like
it's about lifetime value and like
retention like vaynermedia would be a
bad business if every year I had to get
a new people on it it's keeping GE for
five years of happiness like get the
needle to bind your value and the
biggest problem is at those low prices
it's hard to create our a lot
correct so some people mu nu that
because it checks the box and after a
cocktail party they see their in social
media if it's $1000 a year feels good to
them but crime service of the very
countries especially if you're actually
asking for that little amount of money
to pay for your life style pill because
what you shouldn't reading was that
little money is investing example but
you probably have a thousand dollars a
month monthly recurring revenue are you
guys are actually doing the work
if you have one or two below the only
some 24 real agrees right yeah I mean
like the models gonna break man it's not
going to work all right
a lot of you a lot of dollar do you
watch or do it on time to ensure things
you don't already have a lot of pressure
there but I think a big thing that we're
not serious entrepreneurs talking about
actually if you're going out to talk
about mental health the commentary value
depression so one thing is a girl with
Bala guys you like straight up like life
as a divorce like this is only come in
second life under my relationship to
lead to advocate but as you member man I
think
I should check that office in a while I
hear bull for poisoning others life yeah
oh yeah I don't like giving notice how I
don't talk about it pretty much at all
because that's just not smart like
everybody is different
like everybody needs something different
like like you can also just fall in love
in an hour or like like everybody's got
to do their relationship their thing I
think you know I was weird I like
kidding I always kept the constant
girlfriend but in hindsight I did the
wrong that was selfish like I needed
that for like like being a young male or
whatever like yeah I put zero effort
into it I was a hundred percent about my
work if your dog doctor you're not in it
I would have not been because I feel
like this because I feel like I feel
like first why didn't date I had like
you one year girlfriend to year
girlfriend one year like I I did the
wrong thing but in hindsight I feel like
I feel bad in hindsight because I had no
priority of it was not a priority I I
was all about my work and building that
foundation and that's what made me happy
and it was a nice to have it was like
background noise and that's just not the
right thing to do to a human being so
yeah probably I probably do
very thank you coming up
take out take out in here with Andrea
okay that you can do a drop in one of
the best people every millennium request
some it is very questions I've been
trying to forget noon anyway you're the
one came apart
what's wrong clue is coming out fifty
payments are you know how are you not my
thank you like you know the impact
another part that makes me real happy
that I'm a client on every day to watch
your show machine watching you thank you
thank you how many people Jim reaction
and shout to just that one IRA stuff
like ten but the one that really one of
the most it worked
thank you crazy right crazy thing
happens when you ask
I really appreciate my pleasure to thank
you coming out a cyclist never came in
from that goal how many oh great here's
videos about the internship for you mark
ergonomic bouquet today I was assured
you updated it I will not leave you out
of the other can forget say what I let
go I love that
I honestly that USA Today summer like
anybody that really knows me I love that
[ __ ] like that is that [ __ ] fires me
up like like that drives me I love
having chips for my shoulder you know a
hundred percent like I'm super happy I
know who I am you know what I mean like
so it was the reason I threw it up there
is because I can deal with it like
nobody knows what the USA Today is like
if I didn't put that in my answer nobody
wouldn't even know that happened you
know like so for me that that was great
I knew it's a marketing officer tomorrow
at 11:00 on that make a minute I'm sayin
yeah some take up this trip next week
playboy yeah
so that's like thanks for coming thank
you cameraman shooting boy great Frank
how are you ask me you know Joey I'm
talking simply just right now dad Oh
first of all I want to say things well
the conflict without the energy you can
make your videos some people have some
technicality it should Auto scan your
nowhere you know doing that hangover
I've walked with piano
I shall entrepreneurs like Tony Robbins
grand cordon pressure says David they
talked about entrepreneurship and they
took it as an aspect of personal
development I want to know what is your
opinion on personal development with
partnership and success
hi do you think do you think it's a
vital key you think it's necessary I
think we should all personally develop
I'm not a big fan of I think I think the
bigger difference between me and
exercise that you just mentioned if I
don't sell any courses or processes or
events against that [ __ ] paramedics or
something you know like I think they
spend a lot of time on it because it's a
gateway to things they are selling and I
don't brunch that it's just to me that's
of course like if we're not that's like
saying like oxygen is important of
course it's important that we get better
as people that's just not something I
like to me I don't like selling first of
all and second of all I definitely don't
like selling things that are things that
we should be doing like like you know
any like yeah like yeah like I don't
know like I think
[Music]
my biggest thing is like my biggest
thing is just like I just think you
should provide people value and if you
get much bigger it works nobody's going
to vote me in my sphere in a decade
because I'm just going to continue to
give and that's just going to be
unbeatable
and so to me it's like I like to talk
about you know what I got the answer so
I've kept you here because I couldn't
figure it out I'd rather talk about
personal development through my actions
not my words so you know I mean yeah
cool thank you so much thanks coming
this works well I'm talking right now so
yeah hit me up in unison dude that
[ __ ] time it's the most something
like Ghana and everything like when it's
on TV I love it yeah somehow is
involving right now yeah well I really
appreciate everything you do I can watch
all your videos and my girlfriend's like
enough not up yeah no not family good
today
um kiss I mean what turning on Tiana
Tiana
yeah I'm super sorry yeah so basically
my question is um I have an author I
bought a non-profit that I'm doing for
Haiti okay this is a hat right here for
freedom yeah and um basically I have a
question about like I'm not like a model
do you mind we got pistols apartment
yeah and I'm like how do you like I
built like stuff from the bottom bottom
up and because I'm what I want to do
with like I want to teach kids
photography so I'm going to UM
International Center of Photography and
to be taught how to be a teacher and how
- to have more knowledge so I think they
like to hook a photographer thank you I
would hope a photographer - arm go over
to Haiti and like donate like five
people donate and the key there's only
two ways to get things done when you
start from the beginning
yeah you said something that creates
leverage for you for ask and they both
take a lot of work so lean what what
else you what else you're gonna do okay
like you're either going to just ask a
bunch of [ __ ] people that help give
money donate spread the word 99.9% will
say no or you're going to build
something you know money a personal
brand a business that gives you leverage
to get done stuff you want you know like
I took a different route than most
because I just decided I'll spend the
first 10 15 years of my life doing
nothing but working and building
leverage now I have unlimited leverage
right like so just depends on how you do
like listen you know especially being in
Ghana we actually ironically talked a
lot about we talked a lot about Haiti
actually on this trip because he's
walking a bad situation like you know it
was an hour news cycle for you know five
days after the earthquake nobody was
giving a [ __ ] about Haiti let's save
some real relationship to it that
country barely moved since that
earthquake like it is a hardcore
third-world country to make a real
impact it's going to take a lot of a lot
of stuff right and so I think you can't
[ __ ] yourself with how big it is and
I think you got to give yourself
patience so like if you want to do that
that's great
but you have to be honest that you have
no leverage so the only thing you can do
is spend seven to ten years to build
leverage or ask
they got oh my pleasure
good night yeah thank you so much mother
I'm good um I want to thank you because
you indie rock for one of my long minute
dailyvee I love it and I just got out of
school I write record rap engineer all
my music by myself and you're the
background on my phone and the song
sounded a gun that I sent to do rock was
actually inspired by you thank you the
race of life a lot of people be right
back a lot yeah so it's about the race
of life and you know there's many people
holding you back and there's going to be
people who are bringing you forward but
you have to focus on yourself and I work
so I just got out of school I work I get
13 hour shifts like every day of the
week pretty much and I get out your big
old coffee and just go to my studio
right do all this stuff by myself and I
just want thank you so much because you
indie rock especially for music are
giving the outlet to people trying to
get very percent and because honestly at
this point more than anything I want my
blog to be monster for two reasons one I
want to have much influence and impact
as possible but this whole like emerging
artists getting put on that [ __ ]
legendary song that [ __ ] crew like
there's like certain commercials or like
like you know like it's big like Saba's
biggest song is Monday to Monday like
biggest song doodah a chance of rap
album like the biggest song is Monday to
Monday like it's big like like I'm like
oh [ __ ] the way we can put people on yes
cool it makes me happy
and honestly that's all be rock and
tyler and andy and that crew I'm not
cool enough or like for like for like a
book or like you love music enough to
like listen through that amount of the
rock how much [ __ ] does everybody listen
to in the office before we fought you
know yeah and that's why I appreciate
that much man so put a lot of work into
that but that's the crew yeah I
appreciate the photos yeah of course
yeah oh I do a snapchat
sure tell them to lit tell them to
listen to gallows music who's your
account this person is my already know
listen they already know notion HRT
nobody knows to listen to yours yes
thank you so much man
and the song blew up on Spotify
you got me verified on Spotify now so I
appreciate it actually happy man
good luck to me how you're coming yeah
coming check it I just want to know
though by several people the same
question as for the a your take on so I
feel I'm athlete and I feel like you
have that stain repetitive entirely cuz
I just wanna know sure what would you
say to a kid just graduated from college
and you wants to do so much different
things you know before you hit you know
that that that's already a yeah supposed
to do now to set yourself up for those
those coming here imma dabble I would
dabble Cristal I would super doubt the
old people here are men should really
super focused are like that last kid who
just clearly knows what the [ __ ]
that's the only way to answer the only
move to do when you don't know what you
want to do is to then go the other way
and do as much [ __ ] as possible I'd have
like six different jobs I would like
start 14 different companies like you
got a pace you know there's only two I
always say you know how much I love the
word by now right like it's because it
is either you're like me and you like
you knew who the [ __ ] you word and
[ __ ] fourth grade and you never
wavered and that's all you [ __ ] did
athletes have a tough right because they
know their ass like [ __ ] you know I made
that statement the other day I saw that
it must have come out because I saw a
lot of it on Twitter like the 18,000 you
know best athlete you know works at UPS
18,000 best entrepreneur owns ups what
stuff I have so much love for athletes
or I have a we have dinner sports like
you could literally be the 500th best
basketball player in the world and like
the a saddle up being like [ __ ]
Turkey you know thank you think it you
know like like it's just true so so
athletes have a tough because they day
like me since fourth grade
knew what they were going to be what's
great for an entrepreneurs the world is
in play at all times what sucks for an
athlete is there's four leagues you get
the goat and if you don't it gets really
shitty so I
would say for all of you that's why I
got a little louder if you don't know
what the [ __ ] you want to do just do a
ton of [ __ ] like hear [ __ ] like pick up
ballet and like [ __ ] paint and like
cook and like I mean it like you don't
know what you're best at like I was
compared to food you don't know like so
many of you like have opinions about
food you never try the guy you know like
so you got a try [ __ ]
and at 22 by lightly 23 24 25 26 the
advantage you have is you can live cheap
you can all huddle up and live in one
[ __ ] studio all of you [ __ ] good
good right and so when you do 12 15 18
things you probably will be successful
at anything financially so you're gonna
have to live super humbling but if that
helps you figure out what you are I'm
going to [ __ ] a game-changer dancer
my man thank you coming hours all right
yeah of course take it in
awesome incoming
memento I joined to meet your fave
appreciation Thank You senior channel I
love all your videos thank you they're
really motivational your number
thank you my me I'm not like it's a
business going like that but I just felt
like everything seen thank you anything
up in the morning going to work it's
just simple things yeah I don't know I
have the sheets always both luggage is
in such a way that make me go like we
can do that I can do that it's it's
because it's coming from a good place
and I'm happy and people taste it and
I'm happy and I want you to be happy
it's funny I put a dose of it I put a
post yesterday on Instagram
it didn't do super well it's like my
favorite one it's just like I just want
this so bad for you guys you know like
it's a yeah man I get it that makes me
happy man sick thank you mate yeah of
course
I love numbers um how are you I've been
watching your videos for so long and I'm
from New York and I know that you like
wrong be streets so it's crazy that
actually meet you
thing cause I have always thought that I
just like run into you I got a corner
but yeah no but it's a huge group i
watching the Parkers but I just wanted
to say looks super similar to the last
guy like your videos have got me through
some rough time
up and down my career was it's been
tough I actually finally just like got
into music tech business so I'm sucking
have your [ __ ] now and honestly like
your videos I would it be a thank you my
manners thanks for coming out tonight
thank you you're welcome
okay how are you Dan good okay this
night videos are great you help me reach
out to the Vayner sports I was have an
issue in guy you got to your brother on
catheter yep
I talked to David way to talk back about
some things moving on so like blogging
you can store everyone no I think I
think everyone should try it because if
you're documenting and not creating
everybody can do it I just think that
99% of people aren't interesting so when
what I think it's for everybody worked
flying because the cost of entry is
super love and I just think most people
don't have anything to say or aren't
doing anything interesting see I feel
like most the time like I saw insurance
like my life is pretty boring like
Monday through Friday but then there's
times like I do whole things like I was
on vacation I think this work people to
I apologize would no matter what you're
about to say you can't win and vlogging
if it's about the cool things because
you can't do enough cool things you
wouldn't blogging because you connect
with simple you just said I don't even
[ __ ] know where you're [ __ ]
talking about but we can write so by the
way I couldn't but but but that doesn't
mean you got to be high energy and
ridiculous like me that's just my treat
you might be [ __ ] calm as [ __ ]
mundane like they usually connect and a
lot of people just don't know if they're
they've got the face or the vibe or the
connection or a story that connects with
other people and I think it's worth
trying I think it's worth trying
it's nothing else that I mean this is
sounds funny it's nothing else for me
I'll just be funny to look at
like no more I kind of blog you know
yeah that's right thanks like that
thanks what about me of course dollar ll
not my people we should all swap
information by the energies well yeah
you ever you know yeah I got you I got
your phones right
go give your snap coat we won't figure
this out that's what you'll know real
quick got three million Miller spot on
the west side will not exist got it
we're not changing the main I saw that
mounting the brand I saw a little bit to
be clear on what's on laughs oh thank
you very much of it what I wanted to
talk to you about what Claude has been
absolutely incredible can't thank you
enough I have a crush we're going to
connect again these guys are all amazing
almost at the beginning 2017 I want me
to you in Charlotte me because not that
on one night and one night knock it out
but come on using wineries wow so I'm
kind of like I feel like this kind of
funny cuz you know being that i've
swatched you over the years like
watching your growth like I've gotten
excited and I don't even like in this
person here okay okay yeah I got it I
generally got excited for everything
you've done
I have Jeff Jeff Jeff right hook thank
you at my house I read it okay usually
when I'm on the train coming to school
and I'm excited that you actually did
this like as soon as you post I'm like
I'm mistake like I go to school right
there on 34 so I'm like I'm staying in
New York
I live in Jersey upstate New York and so
I see what happened in it was great so I
appreciate you no question you've done
thanks I can't get picture of course
that's it
I really you know what here you gonna
keep this one snap I like it I love this
American I appreciate you my pleasure
stick to my you think yourself Thank You
Man my pleasure
won't work I hope some I want to thank
you so much for still being out here man
I'm really like I mean an hour ago I was
in my PJs and I saw that Instagram post
saying 9:30 Buster's group are all
booked it over here and thank you for
still being out here like I mean
obviously you do this all the time but
for us it means a lot
thank you I'm a little bit of a
preposition so thanks
Jesus man talking to you is really
stressful I
I never thought patent um but um so I'm
in a situation where my father is very
successful
I have not accomplished it yet right you
are on our heads you're an incredibly
wise human being you put out a multitude
of content I don't know how much wisdom
can be packed into one human being but
then you exist and so because of that
you inspire me and I'm at that age where
23 entering the best years of my life
correct yeah I'm about to
hey I'm very keen I give up everything
to be 23 we call all the redo every 100
perception time is the number one thing
like more time like 18 more years a
hundred percent all of it really yeah
100% here here like that's like like you
guys should be real happy I'm looking
young faces I'm like shocked guys like I
was saying there's just a lot of
pressure to be great like him yeah and I
was just wondering like corporate
finance yes I'm in it right now I'm on
the right path maybe uh because he want
you to be a special exactly what he
wants me to be do you want to be a safe
own slightly
I want to be successful I want to keep
proud is there a lot for me I can repay
him by being successful I also want to
be an actor have you ever told him any
of your truth or do you appease what he
wants for now both they're both look I
think look your dad's look do that loves
you way more than he wants you to
appease him no matter what you believe
and I think I think the sooner you can
have an honest conversation like a real
honest one the sooner you can start
doing you may have a conversation with
your dad this summer where you get
really real off the momentum of this and
you may realize when you're done with it
[ __ ] you actually want to be a CFO it
the key is to just have the conversation
until then I'll keep us man maybe but
that's like like busting your ass is
fine and dandy hat if you actually like
this is the thing that you wanted to
bring up I'm telling you as scary as it
may be the real truth conversation is
your mom around and involved does she
know how you feel
does she play the good cop kind of thing
like force like or she kind of like
reinforced like what they possibly I had
a target that hittable that's what they
keep saying hit the target this hittable
right because the acting target the
Broadway the and the Hollywood does a
small target to hit let me give you let
me give you a really really really good
wisdom based saying please do you love
your parents absolutely
I figured based on your vibe if you
don't do what you want to do you're
going to end up regretting it which is
then going to manifest at being mad at
them and you were doing a greater
disservice for the relationship of you
and your parents by not doing what you
want to do then by doing what they want
you to do there's a seed of what you
actually want to do you're hiding that
seed because you love your parents so
much right you're going to then do that
and then you're gonna be 42 and not have
the chance to do your thing and you're
gonna be mad at them and you're to blame
them for it
and then it's going to hurt your
relationship not helping so real it's
really real and it's like it's the
biggest advice I give ticket I love my
parents - like like [ __ ] I loved I
love like I think you're coming from a
great place you just don't realize yet
what the cost of suppressing your own
wants and desires how it manifests and
that's how it's gonna manifest so you
gotta get that thought yes sir oh my
pleasure
either pictures you I got 10% left I
mean I know I'm the charge I know you
got it beep your honor to be gone in
your hotel ok someone or someone to take
a picture I live in New York City do you
really yeah some type of next few months
um this is a flask you got me man I'm
gonna act super surprised I want to be
like whoa Thank You Man ok no no I'm not
cold at all thank you yeah
and make you work hard I'm rising
continue things already that's out there
to be more bhop thank you alright Harry
actually applied for the design
residency before your team during my
lunch break today
good luck yeah thanks so whether or not
I get it or not yes I saw this and I was
like I just want to thank you yeah it
may be the only time I see you yeah and
get all the content projects the culture
stuff especially meaning that you talk
about like I've been on the opposite end
of it where it's not that great so it's
like really impacted me of a patient's
things all the subtle you it's like when
I found you like in winter it was just
refreshing to hear what you have today I
appreciate them there thank you thank
you man I get an S course thank you
making out alright I gotta get out of
here okay yeah I totally freaked out
when I first saw her in town and then I
was like I don't I know he's gonna be
here for long so my question kind of is
I'm 19 years old and you know you really
like kind of trip things around for me I
was always reading books like start with
why I'm like seven habits and of Highly
Effective People but I was still kind of
like sitting on the couch yeah and you
kind of got me or you're like you know
just get up get up like do something I
knew I always wanted to be like you know
an entrepreneur and start a business and
I was like well I'm 19 I don't really
know no one was talked about because I
haven't done anything and I'm 19 again
you know people wouldn't really take me
seriously so what you're saying staying
with the other guy you know just do a
whole bunch of different things yeah
just figure out what you want to do
I'm not entirely sure sure but it is so
you know I'm doing like 3d printing
services like tax results and like
programming web design and I'm trying to
bunch different things yes you're doing
a bunch of things in one narrow thing I
when I give that when I give advice I
mean like go farming and go like sell
flowers like you're staying in like it
sounds actually like you do know what
you want to do based on what I just
heard it's like you have a passion
around tech I think the question is you
think more things within that where you
actually really go rogue and [ __ ] try
to go sing in [ __ ] I mean yeah so
felicitous did it I'm glad you brought
the book so there's something I'm really
proud of that never gets talked about
I've never said it I write books that
expire outside of Thank You economy my
books expire they're not meant to be
these books that everybody else writes
like you just said that are like forever
and like up here right right and even
the book that I wrote that was up here
Thank You economy nobody wants to do cuz
it tells you to do like the [ __ ] that
nobody wants to do so I'm most proud
that I write books that expire because I
want you to read it and do something
about it immediately it's not to be that
valuable in a couple years anyway right
so I think I'm doing is everything and I
think you got to try stuff and you may
want to try more things in the genre
that you're playing in or you may want
to go rogue like I said and you might
think of skateboarding or [ __ ] making
slime or something I don't know but I
think that um I think that cool okay
understood now what like how do you tell
the difference between like if something
doesn't feel right because you're
uncomfortable because it's like not
right for you nobody answered Abigail
nobody's going to answer that but you
can't really feel I can't really feel
what you're saying I mean like nobody
can I can't feel you know I'm pretty
good but like I can't fully get there I
don't know I don't know the good news is
I know you have a lot of [ __ ] time to
figure
just a lot like you can do nothing right
for next 12 years and be young you know
what that's that relief is what I'm
trying to give you because it's true and
once you feel no pressure and go fast
but the reason I'm not scared of
anything because I don't care what
anything and like for real at all right
plus I'm always just doing [ __ ] and if
it works cool and if it's corny fine
like I don't give a [ __ ] like like you
know just like it just allows me that
like I'm always doing and doing and
doing and doing okay yeah thanks and
welcome in yeah 300 u.s. you got it
awesome thanks come ahead
hi hello how are you I'm so nice really
you are I'm from Barcelona and I want to
ask you this one question just talking
about why we talk and how do you deal
with anxious I always connect with your
work because I'm really hard worker and
I get my goals but I struggle so hard
with my entity my you know like I can
handle it
so it's either coming it's coming from
one or two places it's you're allowing
somebody else to judge you or you're
judging yourself that's what I felt and
the reason I actually thought you were
going to say myself I would have bet on
it is because you say I always get my
goals I notice how my only goal is
something that's so outer space and it's
gonna take 30 years you know how shall I
am like my dad or like you know how I
think you know the first time you heard
when I said I was going to buy the Jets
you were really disappointed because it
seems so far away I always laugh when I
see it what's that yeah I mean like how
about 10 years ago even know I always
say like 25 years from now twenty years
smell like I always think that I'll buy
the Jets at sixty right like 65 so like
to me you're just judging yourself in
the micro instead of the way that you
should really do it since that's how
life really is in the macro what you
need to challenge yourself on
is are you really judging yourself or
you worry about what people are going to
think whether that's your mom or a
friend or your sister or your aunt
that's the unlock like once I got to a
place which is super a long time ago
where I just it was nobody but myself
and became so quiet yeah thank you so
much do you understand yeah I get it but
like I would never say because I always
get my goals yeah I don't make
short-term goals you're making too many
short-term girl yeah I live in tomorrow
and next week and next month is crazy
yeah I only live on my funeral oh my god
and that's why I'm so nice and that's
why I'm a delight and that's why you're
so heavy if I had a [ __ ] goal that
had to be accomplished by next Tuesday
I'd be freaking the [ __ ] out yeah you're
putting you know I think that people
think that that's getting them to the
next place and getting the next place
actually think it's actually holding
them back well yeah I'm mission
long-term visions can I take a picture
alcohol by the way he introduced me to
you I think my boyfriend wrestle on a
chili yeah but wouldn't you drink you
with you to keep kind of viewing is
recording on coming here p.m. Christian
pushing clumpy again someone knows how
to get you how are you not you know
regular thank you for coming if you want
to thumping prisoner no thank you so we
gonna be
minutes actually come up here looks like
I'm not really good at like being around
social yeah I guess
I gotta go long story short like almost
like two years ago I got in trouble for
like recharging back one and I go to
prison for too much next month for six
months and when I got out I was really
too sure it was like was when do I know
we wanted to do something photography
okay the long story short year later
after that I found out about you - the
bet the club in a new book so I found
out about that and you were just talking
about younger slugs just go do [ __ ] you
know saying like how you were saying
that so that's when I was alright man
I'm going to Chicago douches dog farm
ago couch-surf around the US and I
maintain and build up my photography
portfolio smart so start off with New
York also sustain New York for like
almost a month I ended up it being in
year six month because so much good [ __ ]
having like Mets way met Andre Berto
Andre workin it go all these people
tell your bathroom fan yeah look into my
day another yeah okay guys so all that
stuff happened and I just want to
appreciate like you inspire me and just
like helping all these people were just
like just like with the knowledge man
who you're looking I'm saying it's just
like it really helped me out it was like
before I became before I even came out
here my dad used to see me on the couch
watching your [ __ ] like for a whole
month I was watching it like every
single day like on YouTube just watching
them what do you say he's like who in
this no because it was it was wrong
because he's like you like that's only
my motivational speaker to be personal
life but you're straight and straight up
with it you know saying yeah let's
appreciate that hi man anything and
honestly want to send you a print like
this is some of my work honestly on a
single penguin I love that saying you
want to clean your ankle over this real
good stuff man this is like off the
couch surfing like cuz you men like did
act like this is all happen you took
action I mean yeah but it came from you
though this is real good stuff man
appreciate it
sure my man I think it's gonna [ __ ] it
up in your country
Jerry at vaynermedia
yep all right thanks for coming are you
a pleasure I clearly did it a route
college yeah I'm not money here money
what do you do in your life talk
oh I am good yeah thanks for Michelle
that's good coffee some love good to see
you like macros maybe Mike who's that
doing following you around
hey leave it cocked good to see you man
how are you
did you see I'll see you later Mike yeah
I got a brew but currently I'm studying
finance and right now going through like
a wall tree internship yep yeah I
watched your hack the internship guy was
on video how would you do that for like
a Wall Street perfect like it's very
same exactly and networking is the most
important thing right if he only it's
the only thing but but that's not an
environment that is as rewarding and
opening to that right which is why
exactly it's the best sometimes it's
very structured with the program so I
can't like really I've done those hack
before in smaller firms but for doing it
like a big bank it's your playground
yeah yeah absolutely I don't want to go
except except for the person that it's
not browned upon absolutely yeah
let's think about it right if you're a
winner and you've watched thousands of
interns go through and be too scared to
say hello and then some kid rolls up and
isn't scared you're the anomaly so I
think at your age with your whole life
in front of you it's better to try pick
the wrong guy or gal and get fired and
or pick the right guy and the guy
becomes the mentor for your whole life
the upside is so much greater than the
downside losing that internship means
dick [ __ ] right getting the [ __ ] guy
or girl that becomes the mentor for your
whole life because you had balls is
everything right yeah it's actually
practical to take the risk
yeah sure if they'd appreciate that all
right you know it's a we know it's just
smart it's just smart people don't see
it that way but just mark you're valuing
the short term internship overall the
whole lifetime upside yeah thanks
yeah all right the rules yeah butcher's
shop
it was very look yes of course I stick
for some checking what my reaction I
don't have one I don't ask myself that
many question okay you know okay I don't
I really don't you know like you know
wander off light was godly I don't I
don't ask a lot of questions okay
like I of myself okay I'm those those
have been answered a long time ago I ask
questions of other people you know but I
don't I don't ask I'm trying to I'm
trying to configure I want to I want to
see if maybe I am and I don't realize it
I don't think I ask myself that many
questions like to me shit's kind of
basic like I know why I do what I do I
know what I'm about like I don't I don't
do well I think people ask you know I
think people do a lot there's a lot of
[ __ ] do I do this or they are like I
don't think that [ __ ]
one case yeah yes I want angel us ever
seen anything of course how you doing
I'm good how he's good actually she said
nice to meet you
thank you thank you hi Joshua
oh [ __ ] I'm I'm a new translation team -
thank you thank you so much for sheet
thank you thank you for doing that -
it's not a problem you know why I'm
doing this because it's very important
for me to have the same voice you have
the same voice and you kind of a mentor
here and I really appreciate your good
intent which is and that you're trying
to do this to do this good thing in
businesses like it really drives me
thanks to you I started to pay your
Amazon yeah right now designing t-shirts
the art yep and I really love you and
you'd like to be on this thing that you
trying to change the world get better
yes just keeps me welcome question right
there
thank you thanks for coming yeah so guys
one I'm just not in charge for what got
the card also pulled over across the
street for we're here how close is that
the beautiful flowering I love it it's
awesome
hydration brother yeah it's a pleasure I
have an active email loved it thank you
to photo man yeah of course I can't
expect your arms Maynard you were half
against opacity 100 I ain't no and I got
denim exactly when you want go Donald
College but great d-roc bingo although
I'll second buttercup their complete
game thank you hey I'm out here I make
music on my third year living in Hoboken
I just got an apartment I just moved in
yes and you know I started out my summer
I was like alright I'm going to make
music all summer but I have not been
able to just get off my hands so what
are you doing insect I can watching just
Network I gotta be honest honest thing
that was the best part of the whole
night and just that truth is real and
there's no there's a deeper reason you
know that right
it's because you either don't really
believe in your music or like I'm trying
to perfect it too much I asked you this
question on Twitter and you said you
have to taste non perfection I can't
want to ask you what do door is what are
you [ __ ] or making up perfection the
[ __ ] is perfection you got your own
[ __ ] barrier yeah you're just not
confident yes all it is yeah and and
that either means that you really suck
or like you think you suck or like
there's just a lot of bigger reasons to
why you're not doing it perfection to
the skies of insecurity yeah yeah okay
right like like people like gone now is
just not perfect it's not ready yet no
no it means you're insecure I think all
my shits the best I'm a little bit like
every day like this episode is gonna be
there's gonna be the video this is the
[ __ ] POG every time like this written
isn't it like and I and I think that's
you just got to put it out yeah like
yeah you're just you're stallin and the
truth is musics hard like how many
people are really going to win right and
I think you're letting those things go
through and like I just want it so bad
like I feel it every
like you burn clearly not enough you're
not doing anything about you rather
watch your [ __ ] house of cards if
[ __ ] step that burn is really soft
seems like simmering smoke you know it's
not a real you you want it ideologically
and romantically you don't believe in
yourself right now in it you may believe
in yourself in different ways and I I
get why you wouldn't you know what I
mean
yeah thank you so you got to just you
got to either do it or stop bullshitting
yourself like like the key is like
either you do it or you don't right like
the key is like stop talking [ __ ] like
either do it or don't [ __ ] say it
ever again yeah like shut your mouth or
the [ __ ] execute yeah thank you so
much I'm in pretty sure pleasure
hey man I'm from my new jersey I love
that photo I'm a big fan love your video
so don't take this you're scared from
Syracuse Columba vendetta French lies
gotten away we buy the right way yeah
captain every day my mom I love it from
it I love it take care of me
good nice to meet you thanks for coming
Gary I'm James Roca I just like Romania
I drove about four hours to get here
well I took the rest three days ago I am
oh my you are wrong the street I don't
know your hours and come on real quick
it up or something you drove more hours
than you've known of me like more hours
and days you've known me for hours
driving three days not knowing yeah it's
amazing
two years I spent travel in the country
volunteering with nonprofits and the
less fortunate I left my job after high
school I joined the Marine Corps and I
dropped um I picked up a job it wasn't
my thing
Isaac Adel emotions course always it
thing of course I learned that I care a
lot about that's good I lived out of my
car for a year volunteer how was the
side mother not to give you a story or
to just ask it quite he went with the
story I guess I did so I feel like I
gave a lot yeah I want to continue and
so I saw your stuff and I was like
that's it and like I knew I knew that I
had to come here and I it's tough
because all I want to do is give I mean
I've literally almost died for what I'm
not joking like I've been in
life-threatening scenarios I've almost
died I've had almost I had rhabdo which
is like so part of the matter I just
want to give and be able to do things
for people good and I feel like I'm in
such a small space
yeah for all the potential all that I'm
ready to get yeah and all that I've been
trying to get like desperately I mean I
live in a space where none of this
exists I'm just constantly thinking
about it's called Phoebe's be peace all
I want to do is give okay
do you see or I I don't know whether to
ask confidence do you know anyone who I
might be able to get connected with if
you see the confidence in me or you
can't be right I show you nothing what I
have to show you that by the passing go
ahead keep talking that I could just get
in and do something I don't even know I
literally don't care my own 100% for me
it's about the mission they're just
about the mission it's my life there's
only reason I'm alive literally I think
I think so I do there's a couple things
I think if you if it's so deep inside of
you to give you need to decide you can
only give when you have something to
give and you have stability in that
giving that can be consistent so you
have like I always say like you can be
selfishly happy before you worry about
everybody else because you won't have
anything to give if you're not good like
I'll always pick me over everybody else
because like even though it looks like
I'm picking everybody else like that's
how you have to figure it out right so
when I hear your story it's like okay
cool you've got to clearly go work for a
non-profit so you can afford to give the
problem is nonprofits are broken right
like and you're not in control right so
like you know I think the question
becomes how do you manifest your give
like you need to like again this comes
down to patience is it better for you to
actually create life of your own take a
pause for seven years of giving in the
way that you've defined it for yourself
right now which is feeling of doing it
every [ __ ] day because you can
actually then make an actual impact like
you have to have practicality to go
along with your passion like passion
without practicality usually ends up
with the person died one way or the
other actually dying like the crazy [ __ ]
you're up to or like just dying without
realizing they're dead so I think you
know the thing that I'll tell you is
like the thing that I'm sensing very
quickly is a lack of practicality that
creates vulnerability and
vulnerabilities is that what would you
consider learning negative no it's
awesome you're not going to pull it off
that's the ultimate vulnerability
I agree with you I have a literacy like
I'm bored even yeah even said it I'm so
I think so I think you're digging up the
question I guess um I'm going to the
place that you need to go to which is if
you we watch this video when I went to
places that you don't want you've made
black and white lines in the sand of how
you want this to play out yet you agree
with me that you're vulnerable to the
practicality I'm trying to give you
tools like I am for everybody in their
own way the only thing I ever only one
common theme to every answer here is
practicality it's got to be able to get
done otherwise who gives a [ __ ] what the
thesis was and it comes in many shapes
from different ways and different angles
and different things but it's not
practical it's like hey you better
[ __ ] like bring value to your
customers because if you don't you're at
a business like like you better taste of
it you're going down the athlete's path
like you know when you have to get when
you have to restart because that was the
place you were forever you need to taste
the ton of [ __ ] like every you know like
you got to like figure that out you've
got to get yourself to a practical place
to be able to do it the way to do that
in my opinion is either one of two paths
go work at a non-profit because then
you're kind of feeding that completely
non through your visceral to that second
time in a row and you better then
actually like build an actual life job
things of that nature and then get to it
later or or make sixty three thousand
dollars a year
live on a $40,000 salary and discard
right so exactly that all right well
it's great like great that means your
expenses are [ __ ] love like I just
think that you have to define like what
does it mean to like give right like
like you're clearly passionate right I
bring up something that you don't like
you're like no no you talk about
something you love you're like yes yes
so you're all the way out here I think
the question that I'm curious about is
like what do you define as giving right
like I think everybody defines that
differently it used to mean the first
things that I told you right that be
real story right I had so much
transition a lot of big trends are scary
that passion is still there you talk
about practicality I'm learning how to
build practicality I can't say I'm
learning I should say on you learn you
recognize that it's important correct
absolutely and now moving forward I have
no idea what I'm doing yeah yeah yeah I
gotta tell ya nobody can tell that I
can't probably before I open my mouth so
you know it's uh I think the reasons you
don't know what you're doing is because
you like a lot of other people in a very
different thing and a quite noble thing
have made a romantic decision of how
it's supposed to go down I don't want to
know I don't want you to like I wish I
know that maybe you can't give me the
answer obviously I'm gonna find the
answer how many of you pretty good I'm
gonna get you I'm getting us yeah I've
given you two things that I know will
work yeah like you can give me the
pieces I need I keep I give you two
paths that are clearly going to help you
one build a business a life thing
completely that doesn't focus on the
giving part so that it's the enabler
it's the fuel to the giving or if you
like so we're insane about giving at all
times let the job that's giving you the
giving be a non-profit thing so you can
learn all the things not to do as much
as all the things to do but you need a
grounded practical engine to this
machine thank you
I always knew I wanted you [ __ ] like
this so you know what I did about it I
didn't do any of it for the first 15
years of my life
Wow
go figure right like like - like yeah
that's my actions like I always had this
in me I just knew that the [ __ ] was I
going to do at 22 just saying this is
what I want to do the [ __ ] this a view
right like I you know and finger for hit
me for hammer looking around up on the
GAVI Bobby around there he is like we
know how young we feel how much more we
can do
you guys don't I keep pounding that
theme because it's true because I said
it before I don't know how many were
here when I'm 19 you know old 41 fell
you know so like I know how you look at
it I also know that you're going to
remember this conversation be 41 one day
me like rocking is right it feels like
it feels exactly like being 19 and when
you understand that like if you actually
want to give for people instead of the
narrative that you want to paint for
yourself well then you'd think about it
a lot differently like that the biggest
thing with giving is what's what scares
me what I don't know somebody is is the
giving actually what's in their heart or
is what's in their heart the way it
positions them in the short term and I'm
not trying to take the cynical point of
view I'm just telling you that if you
really want to give you'd realize that
you need to build a foundation for
yourself to be able to give thank you
welcome may I ask a question that I feel
that everybody a lot of people here
including myself could benefit from sure
most definitely I was raised in foster
okay I
in order to pursue feed peace left my
pen hey head raised yeah
and see I'm proud of that part of my
story because I was hard yeah there's
people you move on from those people
you're like right number seven yeah my
entire family is gone from my life yeah
I get judged by everybody for I don't
care you talk about living on adversity
yeah yeah you know that you know I'll
not say it's not good that's me okay
constant those are the two together two
things yeah I picked up on it
that's me confident is that nothing
drives me more because I look around and
that's confident I mean I believe in my
car yeah yeah it's constant
money identity I don't know what that
means you don't have to be family yeah
what I stand for whatever for me it's
always just been giving I can only
identify through a relationship that's
good and I think that's good so for that
power here you know I mean how do we
create or find you find a now you talk a
lot about I've lost audio videos already
legacy because our legacy yeah your DNA
things like that yeah Mike where does
that stripe mine's not mine is not that
good I don't think I could have seen it
I don't think I could have talked about
it at 23 I don't think you have to
answer that right now you know like
you're going to lofty places through the
adversity and all the different life
things you've had I would just take a
step back and like like you know if you
identify from giving like that's great
and I think that's something you can do
forever
I just want to make sure that you're
able to pull it off instead of cracking
that's the tough part no [ __ ] you know
sir so I wish you love a extract you
yeah really she ate you home yeah you're
welcome
hey you see how I register good good
that's the really weird like 20 minutes
that's happened now I was at the grisly
pair just drinking really good and I was
walking over here to meet up with my
friend who was in South Jersey who
happened to be in the city at the same
time and then I look in this circle and
I see you here and I've been following
you for like the past two years like a
weird like a lot of things have happened
have five minutes and I think it's cool
this is Joey
generally all right you'll sense I feel
like it doesn't hurt Mike that's fine
that's fine
again it I go you're going to like this
story because of our Jersey
I'm from very far Karen love it Walter
New Jersey love it ranek the home yes
Ridgewood good okay um so I just
whatever so when was it in WrestleMania
I want to talk about WrestleMania okay
that's good
want to talk about guys to it basically
Joey is a professional wrestler
I mean I'm his d-roc I love it okay and
I've put together all these crazy
cinematic pieces that kind of takes him
out of the wrestling world and people go
holy [ __ ] like yeah over-the-top stuff
but I just wanted to say thank you
because you're kind of your work
together something that we did Thursday
night the Thursday before WrestleMania
we put on a show in Orlando really far
away from where we live and everybody
said don't do it no one's going to come
out it was midnight midnight Thursday
night in Orlando we had 800 people
showed up off and we had the number one
trending topic on Twitter with Janelle
is Spring Break I love that every other
was just a couple videos that we made
and his social media promotions one
match as the whole show loved the show
if it's the number one trending topic on
Twitter
normally here but the in-game I love it
which is [ __ ] great and Slauson
office but you know is the most
successful winnable successful shows the
sides WrestleMania that
that's huge pretty big I don't really
know you but is there any advice you
give to me right now I'm in a crossroad
professor wrestle for about 11 years now
there's people kind of offer me contract
over the place but right now I kind of
successful through my own continued my
own forget any contract my biggest
advice is to continue to follow down
this path because media what Vince
McMahon understood was content and
distribution
he understood cable and MTV and SM and
what for anyone elses that's right he
understood what every person that ever
wins a big scale understands which is
how to pack content distribution at its
time right now this internet thing I
would make as much [ __ ] content
possible on Instagram snapchat like
become the social media independent
wrestler it will give you all the light
actually effect doing this work no share
any great and they are yeah professional
wrestling promo Bobby what are you
suggest
ah where should we go um what I suggest
is where right here the [ __ ] I think
they're okay with that yes yes okay um I
would uh I I would just make as much
[ __ ] contest but you know what you
guys know what to do video wise use need
to make Instagram and snapchat and
Twitter and Facebook and like and
YouTube like everywhere for the platform
9 second printing is all like 9 second
promo videos of like I'm going to break
your [ __ ] face mad dog Rex like it's
[ __ ] great like content content
content content fit tried and true you
don't want to get involved in wrestling
I mean I've beaten see with us we didn't
see went up we didn't see one else
didn't see when I Corrigan was in the
office I mean I love wrestling
you know we're I know you do I know I'm
just busy like there's a million things
I want to do
I just can't get into everything so I
actually have this weird I told you II
rocket told you I felt like I was gonna
be in a Wrestlemania a couple years yeah
I feel like I'm going to be in
WrestleMania soon like me actually like
because I just thing I'm going to get
ridiculously uber famous I like just
talking about how much I love wrestling
and then Vince is going to want to
leverage my audience and I could wrestle
okay telemedia time is your output you
baby nice awesome they're good to see I
think you climb this one thank you so
let me get a light now and now we know
each other can we go together your
something my name note and snow without
Leno yes
I'm Gary that person I haven't really
watched as long yeah I do know of you
understand so I'm in position where I'm
from outline I'm here honor if there's
just not a student and I do want to be
an entrepreneur just like everyone here
and I'm at that livery where like I know
that you got good advice over there
would you like to try a whole bunch of
different yeah then I also have the
other life around just a student and so
I guess I'm kind of this patent to how
you do a failure but um the other part
of this is Wow how do you how do you I'm
in this mindset where whenever I fail or
even when I could get kind of frustrated
with all the daunting tasks such as
being on or just being together what I
have to do I have this kind of cushion
oh I have school I have like the job
waiting for me how do I get out of that
mindset where but I can like kind of
separate what I have back here so I can
actually go out because sometimes it's
very easy for me to see like that's just
so hard yeah so I think I think that you
have entrepreneurial aspirations because
it's cool right now well I mean even
just like being on internships and I was
even talking to one of the engineers on
our team and it's just like yeah it's
fine and just the internship is that
people and that's like a cool place work
but I just can easily find myself being
part of that like it's just you're just
there every day working somebody else
and even if you want to do something
called Google does be cool stuff but it
won't ever be your project and it won't
ever be something hard to protect for
the world
it'll just be somebody sobriety doing
under Whoville yep and so and even I was
born really like I was raised to be
entrepreneurial minded
but my dad was came from Eritrea I don't
know yeah yeah no and he's never worked
for anybody here he's just been always
doing his own thing and he always really
want that for us but he also really
pushed for because I mean I don't
support a lot of immigrants - yeah I get
it and so it's not that I'm doing it
because it's cool so I definitely see
like the pillows how it is like I'm
doing an internship where I can I see
what the engineering lifestyle is and
know that oh it would be cool now but I
can easily see myself gameís like I own
it then the upsides much better to get
into it earlier like entrepreneurship
because the up because you can eat the
[ __ ] like entrepreneurship is a game of
chicken it's like you versus the game
like it's who's gonna blink first and
when you're younger and you can live
with eleven homies or in your [ __ ]
car it's just easier when you're 42 and
have family and kids and like wrens and
like alien ugh it's harder so listen
it's interesting you're in a funny spot
because you're pulling for like you
basically in a short period time show
tendencies of cynicism to both and like
I don't know I think like I it's funny I
don't give this advice often like I
think it'd be really interesting for you
to do like a four year thing where you
do two years of one and two years of the
other and then come out the other side
and just decide yeah we kinda sorta look
at those things anyway we would like
look for those when you hit up hackathon
it's not up early there was a pre-need
is good listen to be nice but is you
guys did a really good job they really
did suck I mean like I mentored for like
21 hours and they showed like one minute
of film so do like you enjoyed it I
enjoyed it
you don't know why your brand on google
copies of your app whatever you said I
was like yo that was go yeah so like
we've been like you're not trying to
write any Google campaign I wish I do it
like further from here yeah those will
be like real scope move on be more
featured in it yeah whatever but
whatever yeah you got the day up getting
to show the app in the absolutely yes
they did but it's not released yet so
they couldn't feature as well we're
still working on it though time to work
on it whatever I get it
okay anything I can help with I mean
good news I guess because we just
looking for developer right now like
someone anybody developer here you know
anything about a machine-learning or
anything like that yeah word alright so
we could talk after this so besides all
that
besides the whole laughing or whatever
like that so we've been like doing
social media like trauma growth social
review
oh whatever like going like comedy skits
and stuff like that so we were like
trying we had like a couple of our
videos but some of them just aren't cats
like people like repost them stuff like
that
just eyes watch like then one video
that's a survey like don't watch
anything else like these constant
well are they going viral on Instagram
or
well Facebook a I mean so what you're
not captured when they go when they go
well what's viral one of them like a
couple feeders have like over a million
viewers some have like hundreds of
thousands of views or whatever like and
you're not picking up subscribers and
followers I'm picking up so what a smug
is not efficient enough I guess I guess
we still have to work towards it
obviously we got a P persistent that's
that's obvious you have to be credited
because you know what I'm going to say
oh cool but I guess is like is it is
there another way to do you know how
some people win the lotto yeah it
happened is it different it just doesn't
happen to most people like like most
people don't have a video get 800
million you know
morality reach and changes or nobody's
life has been changed by viral video J
like likes not not like people that are
trying to do something consistently like
I know you can bring up one or two
people like I get it but like if you
want it you just keep going and grinding
okay I think you guys I think you guys
are interesting like I remember your
entire page the way you guys rolled
everything about it like I definitely
your met your memorable to me so I think
you should continue to hack okay okay I
mean it all right man we'll take it
thank you good to see you welcome to
three against biggie right here hit me
up good to see you got you a of
collaboration yes I want to thank you
from the bottom of my heart for making
me get that we statutes are in the works
I mean my you this week give me another
one of my heart kid you know how
Illinois you told me people hate to
leave had to believe you can't love you
I mean that from the bottom my heart
because I like see stuff up there you
know you this week coming up giving me
details good to see I think stop by
and I thought it actually did the rally
I love it I got a pretty good head stock
that I'm gonna yeah yeah yeah so my
advice is like I know I'm kind of key to
toggle between life though a brick and
mortar in everything online a gram yeah
what do you look like
actually I still mean toward the
internet I just no upfront cost but
brick and mortar you can put up the
money for a story actually that section
absolutely you want it I want to hear
well I'm not happen then you should try
like like it's a harder it's a way to
leave a good chunk of money quicker but
if you want anyone's will try because
you go let's go back to your nothing you
take a step back to forward you know
what I mean if you feel it the miss
Charlie you're welcome
hi what about that jacket I got you
there you got me but when you're wearing
no it's good you love it
you walk about what's up honey we're a
little dumb big fat cat okay cat we're
up here [ __ ] clock in the morning
lashing the park since one more [ __ ]
war all right I'm heading out so let's
get these last leg three why you're
sending in those [ __ ] this is one
more real quick Brandon
there are lots to do grandma's scarier
which one is your winner you know only
one life stop [ __ ] around and go for
it
yeah I really wanted I really wanna
thank you for the internship video too I
use a lot of weight instead and I never
at that Google I didn't know no circle
go that like you should get a place like
that's all about what you an apology
comes in whether it was a lot about like
Commons when everything I met even in
the ones and zeroes world yeah humans oh
it mattered a lot in the world so you
helped me land my job that Google right
out of Holly here couple months ago
congratulations yeah I guess it's real
easy right yeah never know until you ask
I all on you and your videos especially
back thank you Tom's I think it really
really got me I remember but I guess I'm
you know getting the only real quick
question I have is like what now kind of
thank you I'm in this one cuz your job
but I also want to prepare myself to
potentially do something on my own off
I think I think you don't work I think a
lot of you this dude right here like a
lot of you are so worried about that
like you got this thing right now just
do it yeah like do it right like kill it
yeah just crushed that for three years
yeah like what's wrong with that like
like we're just all judging ourselves so
much we all have so much passion want to
do things like patience man like I know
I say it I know you guys hear it from me
constant
but everybody's questions are basically
like okay cool I hear you on patience
but real quick how do I like like it
like you know like you'll prepare
yourself by becoming a [ __ ] man
you're young man right now like you'll
live life you'll have life experiences
you have context you'll meet more people
you use that internship move more in
your career at a [ __ ] restaurant with
another person you got it yeah I don't
want to do that I'm even here - telegram
I'm glad man okay pretty picture because
Toria
of course yeah question awesome so I
know I'm I'm at the place right I think
we're hit certain things I've been
trying to come again let's say you think
if I find them look how you said I was a
family that is not family that's good
okay right financier - yeah okay bro
it's that okay um what else I think it's
just
door opening I want what response cure
officer no excuses or three or four
often huh what are you doing criminy no
excuses means whatever's going wrong is
just wrong reason one in the earlier
yeah it's [ __ ] the best regardless
it's the best to take blame for
everything it's just better it just
better it's more powerful like I never
want to be at the mercy of somebody else
and when you're making excuses you are
you're letting somebody else
stick to your [ __ ] if somebody left you
with a burden okay
people don't accept the things they
don't like they just want it to be the
way they want it to be and that's why I
do is I just accept it for what it is
it's my fault
and in obviously doing something right
yeah if I want to write like if I want
to like if I don't I don't like I don't
know like everybody blames [ __ ] like
it's funny
we're in Ghana our friend Nick do is
that right yes yeah I mean I'm wearing
Donna for the last five days well and
our Nick do on the first day there goes
I used to complain is to say like I
couldn't do things because my parents
were divorced right we're like sitting
in a village like we were like four
hours from a cloud like we went in it
right and he's like thought like you
start realizing the shipping the fact
that you're standing in America right
now like I just don't have a lot of
energy for your excuses you're standing
in America
in New York City so what happens is
right I play with a white walkers what
happens is to spend no time and energy
on how you got there just spend all of
it on getting yourself out of there it's
just time and energy
huh I don't know I just think excuses
are poison and just suck out energy
every one of us can come up with because
because you know well you and I were
born like not so fun you know not so
[ __ ] fun right I like being
african-american AmericanMuscle fun like
there's better things to be but guess
what there's just so many workers like
not being born at all
worse worse right you know and it's
going to die being Muslim now in the
u.s. not as good as it was 30 years ago
just a timing thing right
being German tonight another better than
it was in 1949 better better like it
just always going to be that way
and the punchline is nobody gives up us
that's the punchline nobody cares nobody
cares nobody cares nobody cares so
you're talking to nobody
and the only one people that care the
other people that your mom and your
other loser friends were like yeah [ __ ]
this [ __ ] we saw this [ __ ] that's
how I feel about it you know and I wish
people knew that that's how I thought
about it when I was weighed in a
different place than I am today it's
what got me here you know now I'm some
I'm empathetic people like yet easy for
you to say yeah cool but like you don't
know it wasn't easy for me to say when
it wasn't it's funny we went to the
village one village and we worked for
like an hour and a half and we're just
blown away by how hard we got
competitive like media or like brand and
we're [ __ ] working there like these
white people are working you know like I
remember just thinking like how
naturally came to me because we moved
from in New Jersey to my parents and
it's like I'm in praise but I just
worked for like ten hours
my dad would cut down trees and I would
have to like carry trees for 11 hours
all my other friends my whole world
they were playing me
and then Tendo that was my reality I
could have been my god you know like
just nobody cares I really got anybody
using any other development watch my
weight yeah you got away when you're on
it okay like there's certain things you
just can't do it right fair enough
well it is very strong demand is going
you Street Bitcoin to particularly yeah
why would it go and you marry stronger
whatever this big tree I didn't mark you
McCauley this yeah so I think you stay
in the life of somebody who's typing a
day in the life of somebody and he's out
to watch anyone last year hello song
don't wait too long the more you able to
connect audio yeah I think you have
enough in those top 100 podcast
literally in four months and people are
following you if you DM them like you
want to come on the show where we like
to shoot the [ __ ] you can write what
everybody wants to learn if you really
know what the fuss is how the remans
here anyway fair enough
morning we amplify that's when I do
social media I knew the [ __ ] I was
talking about I believe that it was
gonna get bigger
look what happened
I appreciate Sony's up [ __ ] for the sake
of Medtronic that's why I hate it but
I've actually looking to go to Korea
good luck - Atticus yeah - friends of
scary D listen it's like [ __ ] 1
o'clock in the morning I'm trying to
leave and it's means like yo can you
make a [ __ ] video for my friend fine
so friends what's up router here what
time is it 12:43 in the morning see ya
[Music]